foreign
[Music]
hey you guys what's going on that's a
good intro it's Friday yeah yeah it's
Friday
and it's another basically open lines
anything you guys want to talk about you
can just drop it down in the comments
section
but uh you know what day it is it's
Friday time to get drunk and yeah talk
about [__] it's the weekend yay so
we're gonna Usher you in to the weekend
whether you have any money or not
whether you're broke or not whether
you're staying in tonight or you're not
we're going to be here talking to you
taking you into the stars with the UFOs
and the aliens
or even down into the crypts with the
ghosts
or over in the dam
back Channel cuts and the prisons where
all the damn serial killers are
you never know who might show up
is that is that a hint that you might
like do BTK BTK my show you don't know
what are you feeling then he might show
up tonight we don't know my channel
I'm getting them ready I'm getting them
ready today
you're getting the money using the power
of my voice oh okay I'm putting them in
the dam
catatonic state
or no it would be a better word for it
putting them in a hypnotic state
yeah catatonic yeah just fall asleep my
boring ass put you to sleep
okay so go ahead and put on your
headphones and take your ride back from
work or get up underneath the covers
with your headphones on fall asleep
listen to Tom and Jetty Yeah Usher and
then the weekend
gently easing you into the weekend yep
Zach says mom had to go to the hospital
again not super serious I'm waiting for
Dad to get back and I'm kind of worried
well [__] I hope everything turns out
okay let me put out some of that
positive energy yeah that's what we're
trying to do I mean you know
that's all we can do I need more
positive energy in my life
it is getting positive yeah I know but
you know
we'll see how things go we'll see how
things go I think it's gonna go good I
think so too but we'll see how it goes
what we're talking about is that uh
Jenny got two really good job offers
interviews Monday and Tuesday yeah one
of them is closer than the other one
but the money's very good
uh it will affect the show
but it has to be done we got too many
damn bills to pay we'll still be able to
do Wednesday and we'll be able to do
we'll be able to do
um Friday night Friday nights it would
just be regular daytime hours yeah it
wouldn't be yeah
and so it's not really going to affect I
wouldn't probably wouldn't be able to do
as many those little reviews of yeah
like recorded ones but I'm still gonna
do them though I just will probably do
like fewer ones I'll just do them like
on the weekends or whatever I just do
that [__] live
well I don't take much time no I don't
really like doing
um doing the ones with just me okay live
you know what I mean too much pressure
on you yeah okay you know what I mean
so probably make all kinds of super
chats by the way super chats are active
and we also have super thanks
but if you're listening to any of our
old shows recorded you can press that
super thanks button and it's like
putting money in the damn jar
like you know when you go to us when you
go to those old damn bars we had the
Piano Man there and he had that big old
goblet big old glass
goblet and you threw a dollar in there
so he could have some change because
he's playing this beautiful music and
that's what we're playing we're playing
beautiful music tonight
that's subjective but you know yeah
uh also I think
I probably should have checked but you
know how [__] organized I am
um I think I activated YouTube
memberships also
I think like if you I think it's like
299 a month there's only one tier I
didn't bother with like the [__] with
patreon I think it's 299 and you get
like little I made little Badges and
like little
um little exclusive emojis that you can
use if you're a member one of which says
Tom spleaning on it and it has like a
little cartoon of like a little muscly
guy that looks like you is it yeah
that's a tip if I'm Thomas Planet how
does that work well that if somebody
gets a membership yeah and they're in
the comments or in the chat or in the
chat I think too yeah it's they can use
that as an emoji oh okay you know what I
mean yeah yeah
I think okay they could buy a time yeah
there's a Thomas plaining one there's a
smell of sanctity one yeah like a rose
yeah
um there's a Pookie sighting one that
has like a little gray kitty face and
what was the other one oh the other one
was where's that raccoon raccoon head
I've actually got to get a BTK one yeah
I can only do four at once like once you
get more members you can do Malik and
like you can unlock more
Tom's blind ass he can't see he can't
see
Zach says uh good luck tasting but
easing back into it and tasting back
into it I know what you meant
um I know how annoying it'd be after not
working normal job for a while yeah I'm
like I'm nervous about it but to be
honest
um I was just getting to a point where I
was just like so constantly stressed out
because I was always like behind and I'm
just like getting farther and farther in
debt and like I'm kind of freaking out
so
you know it might be
I don't know I like I said I was looking
for remote stuff but then I was like I
got two calls from one job that's about
20 minutes away from here and one job
that's about 40 minutes away
yeah that's a long commute yeah but I've
done I've done way longer than that yeah
so I'm not really all that worried about
it the only thing I'm worried about is
like well how long my car is going to
hold up but after I work for a few
months maybe I can like buy it I'll get
another car yeah because my I mean I
don't want to jinx it my car it's a
2004. yeah it's good for a long time it
has it's like that's been a really I
think I bought it used and it was like
kind of shitty when we bought it for
like thirteen hundred dollars I fixed it
up yeah put a new ignition in there new
um
you know it wasn't what he called coil
pack
um change the alternator a couple couple
times
um change the uh
um tensioner belt on the front front of
the motor actually it's the side of the
motor on this one because it's a
transverse engine that's still in front
of the motor it's just the front of the
motor is pointing sideways
um what else do we do replace the
um air conditioner
that was the biggest thing that we did
that was putting new tires on it too new
tires but that's just regular consumable
put new tires on it new pads you know
that's that's just no standard [__]
um but that was like the last generation
of the old Ford Taurus they had that
[__] perfected by the time 2004 rolled
around they were too reliable they had
to pull those things well and like I
said I don't want to jinx it right we've
had very little trouble with it yeah 150
got 160 180 000 miles on it right 170
yeah quite a bit Yeah another paint's
starting to burn off the truck I mean it
looks like a complete ass yeah
it looks like a junker car but it does
run it runs it runs well
the only thing that it does is that the
the front shock towers are so old that
there's uh that there's a sag in the car
and it wears out the uh the the uh the
the same parts of the the tires in the
center part of the tread
replace tires more often than you
normally would it's got a high camber
the front end it's like that yeah and uh
we I took it to the alignment place and
they're like no I can't we can't do it
because yeah the frame the shock Towers
have just sagged over the years right
because the car is so old it's so old
right
so yeah it's almost 20 years old you're
right so that's the only thing it's like
it's not
a deal breaker it's just that I have to
replace tires more often than you
normally would yeah the the only thing
bad about the car by today's modern
standards is that it's heavy Ford Taurus
is heavy by today's standards
and uh kind of slow
gas mileage is just mediocre
it's not great it's not terrible yeah it
had a Honda Fit for a while I'm like I
think the gas mileage was like really
really good but it was like that was
like driving a little bitty tin can yeah
it was like driving a tin can but you
didn't rush how fast it was super late
we were coming back we were coming back
from um the castle that club down Tampa
and then I'd been drinking
and just having a nice calm drive and
looked down my speedometers go to 110
miles an hour it's easy to do and the
car felt like it was just crawling
and I was like whoa had to back off the
handling was fantastic well and there
was no one else on the road yeah yeah I
couldn't judge how fast I was going
and uh empty road what four o'clock in
the morning
and um
man that car was fast you looked at it
and it just looked like nothing look
like a like a Fastback or a hatchback
kind of economy car that that [__] was
quick outrun him I bought that car new
back in 2013. it was wicked for thirteen
thousand dollars I couldn't believe it
Jen picked it up and I was following her
in my [__] souped up [__] Mustang
and she would just leave me the dust I
couldn't keep up with her and I didn't
even I wasn't even she didn't even yeah
I was just because I would do that too
I'd be like oh whoops look how fast I'm
going it was like a motorcycle man super
good acceleration super good handling
and could just stop on a dime it didn't
weigh I mean I wouldn't mind having
another car having another Honda Fit or
another car in that class because like I
said if I get Zach says what are the
jobs for they're graphic design jobs
both of them they're a good job I can't
do [__] else so yeah they're they're
very lucrative even even that close one
even the part time
position which I don't think should get
I think they give her the full-time one
even the part-time well they said the
hours were flexible I think so it's like
I guess you can kind of pick or I guess
it'll it'll probably have to do with how
much uh work they have and [__] like
that I'd imagine yeah even the part even
the part time the money was
significant well like I said that's a
good difference because one I you know
I'm caught you know I have like the big
bills are paid but it's mostly like my
credit cards I'm gonna kind of behind on
them I'm not behind on them but you know
I'm could get behind on them if I'm
don't make any more money and those
patrons which meant we lost 300 a month
over over a few years it just slowly
declined
and I definitely and especially if I'm
going to be working a job I need another
car I'm not gonna I can't afford to buy
a new car plus my credit is terrible
yeah so No One's Gonna Finance me one
she's right at the point where [__]
two or three hundred dollars a month
makes a difference makes a big
difference on her so she's right out the
edge
sometimes she comes up short you know
it's okay you know we can cover it but
it's rough this would [__] be okay
yeah and like I said it just it causes
me a lot of stress yeah you know what I
mean she's just on the edge of not
really making it all the time yeah but
this wouldn't be a total game changer
yeah I would not have to worry because
she would still have basically the the
the income from the show and the books
it's like I said I would still do that
stuff I would just have to do it like in
the evenings and weekends instead of
just working on it all day like I do add
revenue and books and all that [__]
would continue to come
but this would just be bonus money on
top of that that just blows it out of
the water and it would get this place
paid for a lot faster there's a gotta uh
get a new roof on the place
which paid the down payment for that in
a couple months it'll they'll be down
here to change it change that roof
and that's like 15 grand and it's all
going to be Factory well and like I said
Florida like yeah sure like homeowners
insurance are being rolled tools about
um yeah having it having it you have to
replace your roof every 10 years now
yeah which is ridiculous they're making
us
I mean they're an insurance company they
won't take any risk they won't run any
risk on the roof now they want us to
take all the risk and pay for everything
well yeah that's how insurance companies
work [__] [__]
that's why they make more money than
anybody as soon as that [__] gets done
and it's up there the next step is uh I
gotta start planning to replace those
two outside units out there one of
them's gonna go
I'll place the the little one
and then
um maybe a year or so after that I'll
place the other one
because you just have to start in
Florida you have to replace those
outside units before they fail you don't
want to be without and they will and
they will
and they're going to fail in the summer
probably in August yeah oh yeah because
they're working hard for the summer
and uh but this house is good good
insulation compared to the old one they
don't work as hard as they use as the as
the other one did and there's two of
them out there so they're doing they're
they're kind of
covering for each other well this house
is newer than this it's not that much
newer but it's definitely a lot more
better insulated yeah it's better
insulated and it definitely has like
more uh you know it's just easier to
keep cool and matter of fact like this
[__] office up here my office yeah
that we're in right now is above the
garage and it's usually freezing cold in
here yeah which is fine with me because
I have a jacket but you know what I mean
it's just kind of a it's it's an uglier
house it's not an ugly house but it
doesn't get ugly it's not an ugly house
it's just not it's not as cute as it's
not flashy it's not the other one it's
just very like rectangular yeah it
doesn't have a lot of like yeah bells
and whistles are like swag the other one
was like a damn house made out of glass
it was just Windows everywhere which was
kind of refreshing you know what I mean
it had that Florida tropical feel to it
you can see palm trees everywhere you
know and we had it I don't love that
though I like it [__] outside look
like something out of a movie
and and you know when you went down the
street it looked like something looked
like an artificial [__] which it was
an artificial neighborhood out of
Disneyland or something you know just
look real
corporate and [__] clean like he went
you look like you were in the mall or
something you know I like how it looked
um
but the houses were close together these
are all spread out and it's yeah that
was the only thing I didn't it usually
didn't bother me because our neighbors
were quiet yeah but um yeah like the
neighbors were like right it was like 10
feet away yeah like not even and I was
like that's really weird that like the
houses are that expensive and they put
them that close together but here the
houses are way far apart some people are
just especially like foreigners that
move here they love having those houses
real close together that's kind of what
they're used to I guess kind of feel
like they've made it or something look
we're in the neighborhood here where
everybody's all spread out you know the
big houses like this one all are all on
just under one acre 0.9 Acres they
didn't want you to have one acre
because then you'd legally be able to
shoot a rifle on the [__] premises
well some people still do it they still
do they wear it yeah they're still doing
it anyway they're out there shooting
[__] ARs and AKs and
although at the old place you were at
there was a guy who had suppressed some
kind of suppressed submachine gun or
some kind of suppression or and some
kind of suppressed pistol or it was a
submachine gun on um semi-automer full
but I could hear it
some kind of nine millimeter and it was
sometimes
foreign
probably a million dollar at least far
remember the one with the uh the cows
and the
horses in the Big Barn right behind the
walk
yeah you know what was that little uh
that little pathway where path kid he
lives where Pat exactly it was Pat
Kitty's house yeah whoever owned path
Kitty that dude had a submachine gun
illegal they had a lot of lands they had
a lot of land yeah Dave says big Tom
from mannequins has a Chevy Trailblazer
for sale for 3 500 oh okay William
Matrix that's a that's a truck though
yeah
I don't know how I feel about that I
think yeah I think I would rather have
like a smaller yeah I mean I can't like
I said I'm gonna like save up and get a
new car my like I said my my car that I
have now like runs for now but like I
said it's old so I'm kind of like
worried about how much longer it's Gonna
Last especially if I'm commuting for
work again yeah she needs an economy car
that a driver like her can easily handle
and I need something that I don't have
to finance because like I said my credit
is [__] she's actually a good driver
but she doesn't have a lot of confidence
in herself I think
she was [__] chair tear-assing around
in that fit
but she didn't realize it because that
car was so easy to drive
I do have a tendency to speed yeah she
was speeding you know why because I'm
impatient I'm just like let's go I gotta
get there come on
heavier car I got that from my dad
heavier cars are more challenging
when I drove your um your Mustang it was
driving me crazy because it felt like I
was like I have my foot all the way down
on the floor and I was like go yeah that
[__] was not like that fit that
[__] gas pedal moves way down the
floor that's what I'm saying I'm just
like why am I only going 60 miles an
hour this is [__] that that might
fit you could just go like yeah you'd be
like yeah it's because it would not be
like yeah it's because it was all
[__] real modern you know
drive-by-wire type stuff oh we got a uh
we got a super thank you thank you thank
you Jeffrey art about to head to a prior
engagement to support a few friends
would much rather be hanging out with
you guys oh I have a few drinks on me by
the way Tom I'm wearing my fancy boots
tonight
fancy boots yeah thank you so much thank
you so good
I wanted to tell you this Tom because
you'll I'm sure you'll go off on a big
long think about this but granther says
yeah Mary Lynn reichscope yeah just
wrote a book called famish where she
talks about her lovers names were
changed okay she says her first bijer
ever was from a boy in high school named
Dom any idea yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
me
you heard it here first
man we should be
feel like inside she was cute man
she was cute and she was uh she was cute
and she was uh fun it's real fun
you know she's accomplished
yeah that's really funny that she put
that in the book yeah yeah
somebody's talking about you I wonder
how she rated me
we were friends you know what I mean so
we were we were in drama club together
we were always I don't even know like
giving somebody a [__] that's not
really a rating situation that's well I
feel like the receiver would be yeah we
were switching up oh okay we were
switching up I was just gonna say no I
just feel like the receiver in that case
no that was only part of what happened
not the giver that's only part of what
happened oh okay yeah so we'll we'll
have to buy her book and figure it out
no I don't care
let her tell her stories
you do so Karen
um Graham said she also talks about
French kissing Tom Cruise for 45 minutes
for a scene in Magnolia that was cut
from the movie oh okay yeah 45 whole
minutes holy crap well I'm sure it
wasn't 45 minutes in the movie but it's
just you know all the takes they had to
do yeah
I don't know I don't think I'd I would
want a French kiss Tom Cruise no thanks
no thanks oh he's probably cool no
thanks
I don't know you know he's kind of an
uptight uptight guy he probably just you
know takes it all professionally you
know
that's what I mean well and like I said
like don't get attached to me [__] I'm
Tom Cruise
Tom [__] crazy plus I think I've
mentioned this before but I don't really
find Tom Cruise sexy at all
because like I said sexy and attractive
it's like it's it's a it's a complicated
metric I do not find Tom Cruise sexy I
don't know you've only seen his movies
you haven't been right around him he
might you know what I mean you never can
yeah I know that never can't tell he
might be very magnetic you know it's
like it just comes across as kind of
douchey to me like yeah well like I said
that's the movies you know
red of red that you know you can look at
Arnold Schwarzenegger Arnold
Schwarzenegger has made a lot of movies
he's not a sex symbol no guys liked him
he thought he was cool but there are
women that wrote about him back in the
70s and what he was like in the 70s and
the 80s and they said that he was just
intoxicating and that um real addictive
that um
women couldn't get away from him once
once they uh because he kept grabbing
him no they'd follow him around
everywhere I know I'm just [__] stalk
him and [__] you know what I mean
because when he'd start talking you know
he said that he was real um
um mesmerizing and he would [__] and
tell these little stories and women
would just get sucked into his little
stories about dishwater and [__] like
that you know if I can just because
I think the the
Arnold's image through the movies is
that he was real serious
but in real life he's not uh I've seen a
lot of uh listen to a lot of guys that
came up with him in the early days and
um
what he's actually like to hang out with
he's a clown he's constantly clowning
and uh but he was in a lot of comedies
later so I can totally see yeah he's
constantly clowning and uh lying and
making making up stories basically he
was like a proto-troll that he troll the
[__] out of you
he'd have people like somebody would ask
him how the hell did you get so big and
he goes my secret Is dishwater and he's
like what every day when you have you
know after you wash the dishes you know
the water in the bottom of the
dishwasher says take a rag and put that
down in there and stop some of it up and
squeeze one drop into a glass and drink
it three times a day you'll get much
bigger gotta have soap in it he said
yeah that's what he thought it was
telling people and people was like
really he's like yeah
no duh how stupid are people
it was the 70s
it was the 70s and the 80s
you know and silly you should have known
better well this is how stupid people
were I mean well still are there still
people that cannot accept that Arnold
Schwarzenegger did anabolic steroids he
was the keg of anabolic steroids he
would just pop out of our pills like it
was [__] candy
you know
but they're oh he was Arnold's Arnold to
stairways yeah [__] right all those
guys from that era they were just
[__] he was roided out and huge by
the time he was [__] 17 or 18. you
know you can't get that big Naturally by
17 18. steroids
Caitlyn Higgins said have you guys seen
skinamarink yet I haven't but that's my
that an infinity pool the Brandon
Cronenberg movie are my most anticipated
and I see because I've seen a couple of
my horror review channels that I like
have already put up reviews of infinity
pool
um one of which was the guy like with a
really weird expression on his face
going what the [__] did I just watch and
I was like ooh that bodes well I really
do like the Brandon Cronenberg buildings
that he's made so far so I'm really
looking forward to seeing infinity pool
effort it's weird as [__] and I love
weird Zach says uh agreed Jenny Cruz
versus Daniel Craig Craig any day oh
yeah big time Daniel Craig is way sexier
and he isn't really handsome either but
God he's sexy yeah is he straight I got
a feeling dead Craig's gay I don't know
well his character in um Knives Out is
gay yeah I thought he was gay before
that though but I don't I thought when
he was James you know in bond is a
straight character but I I had to feel
it he was that he that that personally
he's gay I don't know yeah I just kind
of had that feeling I've never he
doesn't come off I have never heard one
way or the other or again he doesn't
come off as gay I just had a feeling my
gaydar my gaydar got set off
I just never I don't know I never
thought about it but yeah I thought
there was a good chance I think the
thing about Tom Cruise that I don't like
and I think I've mentioned this a
million times before but it's just like
he seems too much
he seems like too much
I don't know he just seems kind of dorky
and he's just kind of
I don't know he's just like not not
intense necessarily because that's not
always a bad thing but he just seems
like I don't know he just seems too
square and he just seems to
normal and he not normal that's not the
right word either he's generic yeah
maybe that's what it is he's basic he's
very basic yeah he's very well in in the
in the modern like kind of uh context of
that he tries he has a generic kind of
corporate face for his facade yeah yeah
um but he but I've never really been
into that kind of thing because there's
really nothing interesting about that
he's trying it's as if he's [__] real
conventional but excellent all right uh
you know I'm gonna give Tom excellent in
his conventionality yeah well it's kind
of like corporate Superman
um but but I'm gonna uh I give Tom
credit where credit's due he's good with
a gun he can shoot he's gone he's got
real training he can really ride
motorcycles he rides him well he can fly
aircraft
uh he he's physically fit last I saw
um I don't think he's Natty I I think I
think he takes stuff
um
not real heavily but he some
HRT at least
but I think he's done a couple cycles
and does little touch-ups here and then
um
I think he's a good actor he delivers
um but the thing is is that
when you go see a Tom Cruise movie his
audience wants to see that Tom Cruise
character he's always pretty much the
same character but he but he can modify
that character like in collateral he was
the bad guy I thought I thought it was
really good
um I thought he was a great interview of
the vampire he can do other things it's
just that's not where he where his
money's coming from I haven't seen top
gun Maverick everybody says fantastic
and he's just being him
but that that [__] [__] won now the
box office it took all the money and
that's his job make money
so he does it
so you know I just give him credit where
credit's due
not all of his movies do that though
but I thought he was great in in His
science fiction movies I thought were
good
um
it's just like you said he's a little in
some ways Bland
yeah in some ways Bland like I said
that's why and I've never really been
into that kind of thing I'm just not
into the whole kind of
I thought he was a great [__] Ethan
Hunt I mean to be honest like even a lot
of
the kind of real big ticket like that
you know like the actors that are in
Marvel movies and stuff like that it's
like they're conventionally good looking
and they have like nice bodies and all
that other kind of stuff but to be
honest I can't really tell one from the
other yeah like sometimes I get them
confused yeah I'm kind of more
interested in character actor type
people because at least I know who the
[__] they are
overall I like Tom Cruise product I
don't know the guy personally of course
but I like his product what he does uh
it does make money uh that's another
movie we need to see Tropic Thunder yeah
I haven't seen it that's another one
that I keep wanting you to see because I
think you would really like it yeah
because Tom Cruise I'm sure I would
everybody loves it and he's actually
that's one of the roles where he's kind
of like more comedic yeah so it is
actually really funny he was good in
that Fourth of July one too the Vietnam
yeah I thought it was good
um so no I give I give him I give him
credit where credit's due I think he I
think he's is he a great Shakespearean
actor no he's just a dude that delivers
at the box office
um
like you said he's a little Bland but
that's the character in the writing but
that's what he's for you know that's
that does
people are paying to see that that's
just a
I think you know if you want to have
wide wide you know appeal and get a lot
of you kind of have to be a little bit
in the middle kind of generic I think I
think it sells real well yeah I mean
well and I think that's kind of the
problem I have with it too is that it's
just you know it to try to please as
many people as possible it's like you
have to be as Bland and generic as
possible and so a lot of them tend to
like kind of look the same and kind of
act the same and kind of have the same
thing going on and that doesn't really
interest me all that yeah but the thing
is I don't think he looks generic
he looks like Tom Cruise he's got his
own thing he also he's got good
physicality and a lot of skills you can
buy that he did some [__] they show they
so show him do some [__] on screen and
you can buy that he did it because he
probably did do it
so if he was really generic it would
have been you know what I mean it would
look fake as [__] and somebody else
would have done it for him you know he
wouldn't be doing his own stunts and it
he's not like that it's just that the
roles that he plays are kind of generic
roles that's part of it too you know uh
their their
kind of corporate
acceptable guy you know everything's
about him usually he's pretty acceptable
that's why he did collaterally played
that dab psycho [__] hit man I
thought that was a good good break from
what he normally did I you know I liked
it
um
but he he can't make a living doing just
that you know I think his audience wants
him to be basically you know Maverick in
Top Gun or Ethan Hunt and and uh you
know in uh Mission Impossible which I
thought was great series each one of
them kind of was uh really good for the
time you know one of them was a John Woo
movie and then later on with Fallout was
almost like something out of them
the new James Bond flicks I got them all
I don't have the brand new one though
um or the last one that came out last
one I had was Fallout I think
but um
I think I gotta go check my catalog
so Camp guy says uh like my 24 year old
son he's not that good looking but he
attracts the ladies like I've never seen
he's a blue collar guy wears a tool belt
and a hard hat at work
there's a whole like sub-genre of like
fantasy like erotica for that
slasher Fred says since you have
reviewed the Ghost and Mrs Muir one of
these days you should watch and review
the 1940s comedy Arsenic and Old Lace
I've actually been wanting to do that
one yeah we should probably do hush hush
sweet Charlotte also since we did
whatever happened to Baby Jane
uh Tom Sykes said Tom Cruise is an idiot
for not putting out enough for Mimi
Rogers yeah well
then Tropic Thunder some one of these
days you should review Risky Business
uh granther says what would Tom Cruise
think about kissing the same mouth which
smoked Dom's bone that's what I yeah see
now that you now that you mention it you
know that whole Six Degrees of Kevin
Bacon game you were only two degrees
wait is that one degree or two degrees
for the Tom Cruise yeah man Tom Cruise
hitting the same chicks yeah
oh now see now you can tell people that
like when you want to impress them yeah
oh one surprise me if you got some of
that it wouldn't surprise me
Mary that was cute man she got cuter she
went oh what happened
and she was funny my computer wanted to
restart and I was like no don't do it
hopefully it's not going to restart I
told it not to what oh my computer came
up and said um it needs a restart but I
said restart it tonight and it's like
okay but then it like flashed at me like
it was gonna do it anyway
I was like all right well I think it's I
think it's all right yeah I think it's
probably ignored it it just opened the
the settings window that's fine yeah if
we lose our connection we'll just pay it
because I was like what is that flashing
at me yeah
uh Zach said I actually think Michael
stolberg is kind of sexy too I don't
actually know who that is so I'm not
really sure uh what you're talking about
but I'll look him up later Tom Cruise
Tom Cruise is one of the last true movie
stars though I don't think there any
nobody else is a movie star nothing none
of the newer ones
think I wanted as a movie star
I think Tom was like that the last of
that breed there may be another a couple
of them that are with him but are from
that same generation
nobody else is really a movie star
you know
unless you guys can think of somebody
well I'm having a hard time but like I
said it's just because I don't
um usually watch those real big Temple
movies like you know what I mean
um
Tom Sykes said I just saw the 1993 film
Blood In Blood Out and I must say it was
a good ass film Tommy you'd probably
like it it's free on YouTube what is it
we should check that out what is it we
did start watching after the show on
Wednesday night like even though it was
kind of late
we actually did start watching uh the
ghost of Flight 401 on YouTube we're
starting to fall asleep well we started
falling asleep and also it's a terrible
terrible copy terrible like you could
barely see what was going on you could
barely hear it because I it would look
like somebody had taped it off TV yeah
back then and then they made it you know
they were just a video and so like there
was just like this hum like in the
background it was like drowning
everyone's uh dialogue out so we only
got to the part where spoiler alert
Ernest Borgnine died in the hospital
yeah and then I was just kind of like I
don't know if I can watch this anymore
because it's like it was not a
compelling story either it really wasn't
it's like you would think that you know
something about a [__] plane crash I
mean admittedly we didn't get to The
Haunting [__] yet yeah but all the build
up at first I was just kind of like will
someone die and like haunt some [__]
already yeah like I'm kind of over it
and it's like well I think I was just
mostly mad because I couldn't see
anything like they're all in the cockpit
and it's like I'm like I'm like it's
dark it's like all I can hear is like
people's voices mumbling and it's just
like I can't really tell what's going on
so we just kind of gave up on it yeah
but you know I don't know why I might
finish it one of these days but
I don't know I mean we had been watching
um I've actually been watching because
remember Oracle recommended the on Hulu
I think it's originally on History
Channel but they have
um the food that built America that
series and we've been re-watching that
that series it's season three they just
put up
that series is [__] fascinating I
mean all of those the whatever that
built America there's the men that built
America the Machines That Built America
there's all kind of different ones but
the food one is to me like the most
interesting because I'm all into food
but
um yeah like we watched the one we
watched last night well we watched a
bunch last night we watched one well we
had to watch the one because it was
about Little Debbie's it was Little
Debbie's versus Entenmann's
there was that one and then there was
one that was like Taco Bell and Arby's
and then there was one that was Benihana
and TGI Fridays and I don't know if you
guys know this but TGI Fridays started
out in the 60s I want to say as a
singles bar
in New York City and it was funny
because you don't think of it nowadays
because everybody just thinks of it as
like a restaurant with a bar attached to
it with like you know there's lots of
restaurants like that but back when TGI
Fridays opened nobody had this concept
before yeah restaurant with a bar they
didn't have that concert well because it
was the kind of thing where during this
time period like they were like well
single women didn't really go to bars
like Bars were like dude Hangouts they
were all like Dives and they were kind
of scuzzy and it's like you would you
know like a respectable woman like a
single woman wouldn't go to a bar like
by herself yeah they weren't even young
guys in those things yeah they were old
guys back then in those places just
filled with [__] cigar smoke
those guys so like one guy was like
sitting in there and he was like why
aren't any single ladies in here and
they're like what the [__] are you
talking about single lady wouldn't come
in here and he's like maybe I should
make a place where they actually would
come so it's kind of like a bar but also
kind of like a restaurant and it was
kind of I don't want to say TGI Fridays
is classy but they made it kind of like
classy than the bars at the time and
nobody had done that
whenever it started and so it was like a
massive massive hit like in the middle
of New York City they said there's
[__] lines around the block and [__]
like that which is crazy I was just like
I didn't even know that that's how it
started but that was that and then there
was another episode that was Famous Amos
versus well that's not verses but Famous
Amos and um Mrs Fields that was another
one
but there's one I don't know how many
more there is there's a pasta one that's
the next one but I haven't watched that
one yet
and also tonight I might have to watch
the new Gordon
yeah because they probably put that up
John is saying I don't know I think
Arnie and Sly were movie stars also yeah
I guess you could say well as I said
there are some movie stuff like Yeah
from that era they're all from that era
uh there aren't any newer ones that I
can think of
um
they were movie stars
I Gotta Give it to Sly though over time
this live beat Arnie over time
just went to what he
he could produce stuff
you know he could write scripts he was a
lot more talented
John Smith said in the UK wine bars
tried to appeal mainly to ladies in the
80s yeah
yeah I mean that's the thing I mean like
nowadays like I guess women don't really
care about going to bars and stuff but
it's just funny to think about back in
the old days they didn't really there
was no internet back then so yeah
nowadays I think all the young girls
meet everybody online dating apps and
[__]
well I'm just saying there's no Stigma
about women like single women groups of
single women or even single women on
their own like going to a bar or a club
like by themselves is not that big a
deal you know what I mean but like back
in the old days it absolutely was I
think it depends on who you ask
like yeah it's not a big deal to us but
I'm sure you could go out to [__]
Alabama Mississippi and there's your
people oh my God I'd never go you know
they got some they still got religious
people well now I'm I'm not going to say
now there are some bars that I
absolutely would not go but to by myself
but it doesn't have anything to do with
like morality or anything like that I
said well I'm probably just gonna get
roofied or it's like a [__] dive in
there or something like that straight up
meat markets too yeah I don't and I
don't really like places like that like
I grew up in Daytona Beach and there was
a place I think I don't know if it's
still open or not but there was a
nightclub there called what the [__] was
the name of that place Razzles that's
right Razzles and you just know that
that's what kind of bar it was just or
Club it was for the name but that was
just kind of like where everybody that
was all the where all the basic people
went yeah basic [__] just and and
jocks and [__] yeah and it was like
right on it was right on A1A which was
like the Main Street like right now they
kind of tend to be expensive too because
they're ripping those people off sure
and you go in there and [__] they're
all based they're just there to get laid
and nobody knows anybody nobody's really
a regular that's another weird thing
they're not really regulars there there
isn't really a scene there those people
might go there only once maybe once or
twice a month maybe or excuse me once
every two or three months
some of the ones that you know they're
[__] I knew about
yeah I haven't been in any place like
that since uh I was in the Army in
Nashville they had a lot of those yeah I
don't even know if there's places like
that anymore I mean there are I guess
but I don't yeah there are I wouldn't go
to that there are because remember we're
at the falcon
yeah some of the people in there came
from a place that was like that up a
street that's right remember boy did
they come into the wrong place
[Laughter]
well the Falcon is just like it's small
it's not a club it's a tiny tiny tiny
tiny bar yeah
granther said would Jenny go to the
Oasis on a Saturday night by herself
absolutely not absolutely what's the
Oasis that place you go all the time oh
that oh that Oasis
he goes there like twice a week and he's
like what are you talking about no Jenny
wouldn't really set foot in the Oasis I
went there once yeah but I mean during
the day it was fine during the day yeah
during the day I wouldn't go there by
myself though no [__] that now see I
used to go to ibar by myself and I
didn't have a problem with that
I never had any trouble not really no
not an eye bar no
well I knew everybody yeah
you know so it's kind of like different
when I knew everybody that worked there
and I knew a lot of people that were
there yeah and it was usually people
that wouldn't bother you yeah you know
so I I went there by myself lots of
times like back in the old days yeah and
it really wasn't a problem at all you
know every now and then yeah people do
get roofied places but
it happens that's not regulars doing
this but not yeah it's not that's not
people we know doing that yeah yeah as
far as I know it's usually just like
rando's walking through there
John Smith said in Glasgow we have the
final tradition of old man pubs pubs and
bars populated by mean old men that
don't want anyone under the age of 40 in
there
I always kind of wondered about if they
still had that going on like in this day
and age because I know that the Oasis is
kind of like that yeah it is kinda it's
Grumpy Old Men yeah during the day
the the clientele changes it depends on
what day it is and what time it is
Sunday it's all it's all bikers all day
Saturday probably too but Sunday's the
big day because that's when people are
off work and they're riding
so it's bikers and their girlfriends
nighttime I think it's more of like a
damn
country
like a country-ish
or a redneck [__] Meat Market I think
during the during the nights there's
fights happen there and they're playing
music like [__] Kid Rock and monster
truck and [__] like that
but those bikers aren't in there
those hours
um
but no Sunday is the big biker day
and it's just like I said just during
the day weekdays
from noon to about five it's grumpy old
drugs old guys and old women well yeah I
mean it's like a weekday and they're in
a bar drinking in the afternoon in the
afternoon yeah so you know that should
tell you something right there yep so
hahaha
Graham says uh old man pubs bitter gray
hairs take talking [__] about politics
young people Ex-Wives and how the world
is going to hell in a handbasket Good
Times yeah it really doesn't seem like
that fun but I mean I guess they're
having fun like in their own kind of way
but the Oasis they're not talking for
the most part they're just sitting up
there drinking they're just sitting
there drinking and you know I'll be
playing a jukebox the Jukebox gotta uh
it's you you got an app for it and you
can pay for it directly through your
the count you know and um
they got all these different functions
that you could do so I started [__]
with them you know by playing [__]
[__] like Ramstein and stuff
well they're in there mostly because
well and they're alkies and two
um uh the uh the bartenders [__] pull
their titties out all the time
it's part of it
so you know they'll pay them more they
flash them they give a bigger tip yeah
but our the thing is is only an old guy
would really care about it those girls
are not really hot you know well that's
what Amy's the hottest one
yeah really and she's my age you know
it's kind of skinny fat skinny with big
belly and [__] big old titties
well that's the thing once you get to a
certain age I guess you kind of take
what you can get you know those dudes
are in their [__] 70s and [__] all
right hey whoa you know for them that's
like a big deal hey woo beer they're
also they're also from a generation that
would
find that interesting
seen every [__] day this [__]
crazy ass clubs that we go to you know
use the same bedroom go to Hooters and
think that was great yeah
so that would be [__] boring you know
well I mean you know I don't I don't
like the whole vibe of sports bars yeah
yeah
yeah and I don't like the people the
kind of people that go to sports bars
and I don't really like I just don't
like that whole biker bar is a trashier
version of a sports bar yes I've always
found that on that yeah yeah and like I
said I grew up in Daytona Beach which is
like real rednecky it's like it's I
don't know what it's like now because
I've been I don't go there very often
anymore but it does have that red necky
kind of like a Vineyard to it yeah that
kind of trashy right kind of thing and
it was like that you had yeah you had
like two tears you had you're kind of
like slightly upper middle class kind of
like more yuppie-ish kind of people and
they would go to like Razzles and then
you had like your [__] rednecky ass
people who would either well you had
like your slightly up Market rednecky
people that would go to The Rockin Ranch
and then you would have your scuzzy
biker type people that would go to like
the Cabbage Patch which was like a yes
um
it's most okay not all them bikers are
the same though either like um this is
this this is this is my main friend down
there that's Chris all right hold on
Chris he's also a veteran
and he's got a real neat that's him
right there he's got a really cool
Triumph Rocket three [__] does a
bunch of steroids and [__] we'll sit
there and [__] talk about steroids he
got hurt and gained a bunch of weight
his face got [__] fat as a
[__] and he's talking about man
I gotta get this [__] my cheeks are
getting too big see how big his cheeks
are he hurt his back
so he wasn't able to work out
but he's back he's back in the gym now
but that's what that's the place it's
just that
that's what it's like during the day
you just hanging out [__] catch up
with each other
look at people's motorcycles
what I was taking a picture of out the
out the door was like a dude's they got
one dude that has a [__] ton of classic
cars you messed my lighting up that's
all right
they gotta they gotta do it's got a [__]
ton of classic cars like
mid to late 60s late 60s Camaros and
[__] GTOs and [__] he must have eight
or nine of them
and uh the dude's a total wreck man
[__] what he's late 60s
overweight can barely talk because he's
constantly [__] drunk but he's gotta
he's got about 10 of these [__]
fantastic show cars that he builds
and just drives them around takes them
to the takes them to that place I've
posted videos on them before on my
Instagram
he's got some really he does great paint
and everything and you look at the guy
and you're like and he actually does it
himself and you you wonder like how the
hell did he do it he's in such bad shape
you know but
when there's a will there's a way you
know
I mean I'm not going to get on anybody's
case for like you know being drunk
during the day because hey but you know
you know I do that [__] too but you know
so I can't really get on anybody's case
but it is kind of like
I don't know I know there's not much to
do around here but
uh well there isn't much to do around
anywhere at our level
because you could say everything seems
to be boring to me now
well that's not good I've done
everything oh you have not I've done
everything
you have not yeah
Ben Farrell said day drinking is the new
golf yeah
I drink about three four of them
granther said I had a buddy who would
always talk to the bimbo waitresses out
on dates or ask the bimbo waitresses out
on dates he thought they were digging
his Vibe and sense of humor I was like
dude they're just putting up with you to
get a good tip I mean that is a rookie
mistake yeah that is just kind of like
don't chase this don't don't chase the
hell I mean yeah
I feel like every like every group of
friends that goes to somewhere like uh
you know Hooters or something like that
there's always one that's like man she
digs me I'm like no she doesn't just
knock it off she's just being nice to
you to get more money
and it's like I feel like most dudes
learn that by the time they're like in
their 20s but maybe not maybe not
John Smith says do shrooms for breakfast
to liven up the day sure I could see
that I could see that
John Smith said in the northeast of
England until fairly recently we had
working Men's Clubs men only clubs yeah
um there were some bars here that were
men only but I think that was maybe only
until the 1970s
like actually watching that um food that
built America show
here was something that I didn't realize
remember when I said a long time ago
that I didn't realize that a woman
couldn't get a credit card I think in
her own name until 1974 which is crazy
because I was born then that was like in
my lifetime
um for a long time they were actually
talking about Mrs Fields cookies and
they said she couldn't get a loan to
open her business in her own name like
her husband had to sign it and then
um I didn't realize this but they said
actually it wasn't technically legal
everywhere like I guess on a federal
level for a woman to like take out a
loan for a business and everything like
that until 1988.
was when they passed that and I was just
like are you [__] serious right now I
was almost out of high school at that
point
that's crazy I never realized it was
that late
all right so if you guys uh have any
subjects you want us to talk about go
ahead and uh any questions or anything
you can drop them off into the damn
comment section if not we're just gonna
bore the [__] universe and uh the
entire internet with our tales about
being drunk at the damn bar and uh
whether or not a woman could have a bank
account where the uh what's boring about
that ah just like a boring let's talk
about let's talk about something oh and
oh and like all your and you talking
about uh steroids all the time just like
girls Super Center yeah yeah yeah it's
all boring it's all boring well okay so
well if everything's boring why are you
all here I'm drinking stop trying to
drink I'm trying to drink man now look
the next thing you know [__] BTK is
gonna show up in this [__]
yeah where is he at he's over he's right
there I can see him I'm gonna get him
ready you're gonna get him ready you
want to get HH Holmes next to him he's
HH Holmes okay I don't know I don't I
don't know H.H Holmes's voice well
nobody knows H.H holmesis he hasn't
spoken to me from Beyond the Grave yeah
oh okay he hasn't spoken to me girl
look at look at him
look at his head bobbing around yeah
these are [__] great man somebody
sent somebody sent these to Jenny Sophie
says yeah that's right with Sophie right
yeah yeah that's because I was uh did
she send HH no no no that was somebody
that was said that was yeah somebody
else but speaking of Sophie Sophie's
gonna be coming next month yeah that's
right she finished it and she'll be she
wants to do a uh um the Friday it's
gonna be like Friday the 24th or 25th I
think of February of February yeah yeah
so she'll do the show with us and then
we're gonna go out to mannequins
so uh David will be able to meet so
soap's only done one show with us before
that was a couple years ago yeah that
was when we were at the old house and
we're at the old house
so she's gonna be here for about five
days and then she's gonna go back to
Michigan
but um so that that should be fun
um
what else
John Smith said I discovered something
recently and Switzerland women could not
even vote until the 70s yeah I had heard
that actually I had heard that
I don't know what the [__] deal is
man we'll give us nobody well let's vote
on nothing I mean I know what the deal
is I know what the deal is but it's fake
anyway
no matter who you vote for they've
approved either candidate they only they
own them all by the time they get to
that level the rich people will always
win The House Always Wins
and it's just a puppet they don't do
anything
they had that they had that what was it
uh
Princeton University I think it was did
that big study
to analyze government activity with um
elections and laws as they pass through
the Senate and like consistently 99
everything was against the people and
four whoever paid for that law
over and over and over again so it's not
a government really it's just a machine
that's sucking you dry like a parasite
because it's all paid for
Ben says I thought you had a new kitten
called BTK I would never name a kitten
BTK no that's I would never say with
btk's first name again I forgot um
oh [__] what was his name Charlotte yeah
oh Dennis don't break his head again
Camp guy said my parents got a small
business administration loan when Jimmy
Carter was President as a minority
woman-owned business mom had 51 in debt
at 49. yeah that's just that sounds
about right
and let's see Ben says giving women the
vote signal the destruction of Western
Civilization uh yeah okay
you do that
what are you even talking about
it'll go I don't know it's just yeah I
know you don't know
I don't I don't I don't I don't think I
don't think voting matters they've got
that system totally rigged anyway
I think it was always like that it was
just the illusion of choice is what they
had done because I can't see I can't see
oligarchs rich people and companies that
own this government I can't see them
given people especially regular people
any say-so in anything so I think it's
just I think it's just fake
John Smith said I have a cat I'm
convinced is Jeffrey Dahmer reincarnated
because then he enjoys killing stuff and
playing with the bodies that's kind of
all cats though although I mean I don't
know if Pookie necessarily enjoys
killing stuff she does play with she
stopped killing the lizards yeah
she likes to like play with them but I
think she realizes that it's like oh I
can't play with them too long or they
stop moving around yeah she's gotten to
the point where she lets him go yeah
so she's you know she's kind of learning
she doesn't she doesn't need him anyway
now like I said I had a cat that used to
absolutely eat them except the heads she
would just like leave little lizard
heads all over the place we'd find him
like out on the front porch granther
says talk about tasteful goth Home
Furnishings turkey necks and family
members Abraham Lincoln hero or villain
viewers you miss uh that you wish were
still here I guess that's what you mean
uh Abraham Lincoln villain
everything you know about him is a lie
it's fabricated it's pseudo history uh
again a dude named razor fist who's from
the north he's not some kind of
Confederate sympathizer and he's from
the north
um did a really good show on it and gave
all the quotes
all the independent Witnesses people
that were from Europe who watched the
whole war of secession go down and
everything that that
um that that Lincoln and the in the
lincolnites did it was all uh one-sided
and um bad
extremely unpopular in both the North
and the South
uh he quelled a bunch of uh riots and
uprisings even in the north of people
that didn't uh counties and states that
didn't want to
fight the South
um didn't really free any slaves uh only
freed slaves that were in the
Confederacy and not ones that were in
the union it's all just uh and really if
you look at the Lincoln Memorial the
Lincoln Memorial he's sitting there on a
[__] throne and underneath each of
his hands on the front of that Thrones
are is the fastest
which is the stick the bundles of sticks
which is a symbol of fascism you know
and then you know they're talking about
we're under a new perfect union that was
the beginning of the American Empire and
the end of the uh of federalism where
states joined the union willingly and
had the right to leave it willingly it
was just the beginning of of the empire
I always thought that now was kind of
like the time of like Julius Caesar a
good analog you know the end of the
Republic in the beginning of an Empire
no the Republic died a long time ago
1860s maybe even before that
because the robber barons were
were really getting in the bank the
banking cartels were getting a really
big grip into the into the system and
the people none of the people were
really being represented in any of the
states
it's just that we uh everything's been
kind of
propagandized and glorified the past
the past wasn't very good
uh
oh yeah back in the day when [__] ran
well it never ran well
but uh Lincoln himself was jailing
anybody who spoke out against him in
even in the North
uh uh jailed a bunch of newspaper
reporters who uh said hey man this may
not be the right thing to do maybe we
should let the let the South go
uh you put too many tariffs on him
anyway it's taxation without
representation there's just a bunch of
arguments against Lincoln
the whole thing about Lincoln being a
hero was like after the war and it was
just a it was a creation of
of Washington D.C it was a bunch it was
built upon a
stories and propaganda
uh no he wasn't that good he wasn't good
at all he's kind of like the America's
version of Stalin there were
concentration camps in the South and
everything the style and killed a lot
more people
but
Lincoln killed a lot of people too with
his policies
um they even
he sent Sherman down here and Sherman
and his wife actually discussed in the
letters about the outright genocide of
the southern people black or white
Sherman's Army hung just as many black
people as they did white people
it's all there they got photographs and
everything to prove it
it's just
not as bad
well Show's not fun anymore well he
asked me
let me go uh make another drink
yeah I guess I could use another one too
okay
um viewers you wish were still here I
still wonder what happened to
Sandra The Peanut the German peanut
butter Ambassador and Tila
and I haven't heard from either one of
them and I kind of hope they're okay but
you know I understand like life happens
and [__] like that but you know what I
mean
so I you know I kind of miss them but I
don't really know where they went to
because they seemed like they were here
all the time but now they're not here
anymore
um tasteful goth Home Furnishings
there's kind of a whole thing where
it's you know what
um nowadays it's a lot better there's
kind of like an embarrassment of riches
because
I think that you know uh home decor like
manufacturers and stuff like that they
actually realize that there are people
out in the world that want
Halloweeny looking or spooky looking
stuff like all year round but they don't
want it to look like a [__] like I
said like a JC's haunted house in your
[__] like all the time so they'll make
you know kind of like black or kind of
creepy or Victorian looking versions of
[__] that you can use all year round
that looks spooky but doesn't look like
Halloweeny you know what I mean because
like I said I have like um
I follow
um on YouTube like Jade the Libra and
she's real big about like you know
Halloween decor hunting and stuff and
that's usually the kind of [__] that she
looks for too because she likes to find
things that you can use like all year
round you know not just
you know so you can't just like slap
[__] jack-o-lanterns and [__] like
that over everything it's cool with that
is that is like it
Halloween time you don't want your house
looking like that all the time I mean
yeah or maybe you do and it's that's
fine you do you
you do you you know
uh let's see what else
turkey necks and family members
like well no you can talk about [__]
turkey dicks why not what's the matter
with turkey neck what he's talking about
he's talking about my dad well I don't I
know
well no I'm talking to the audience I'm
talking to you remember the audience may
not have been with us for long enough to
know what why he's asking about turkey
necks
a couple years back with my dad
had to go get bypassed surgery because
he was dying of this heart attack thing
that kept hitting him
so um
he got the bypass this is a triple
bypass
and the woman that lived across the
street
um
I guess he's kind of sweet on her she
comes and checks on him all the time and
she's real good looking black woman
and he's friends with her husband her
husband is a National Guard guy he's a
uh Sergeant First Sergeant
of the local National Guard over there
in uh in Mississippi and Heidelberg
and she checked on him every day
make sure he wasn't dying okay he still
checks on him every day
so he he uh he likes her
she would bring him turkey necks
every now and whenever she cooked turkey
you could get turkey necks in
Mississippi for nothing
and uh
he told me
is he told me on the phone long before a
little heart attack he goes my neighbor
brings me turkey next man and I didn't
realize how good them things were and I
was like really good oh man she could
cook them things those things are gonna
be fantastic he mentioned that too
so he comes out of surgery and he called
me over to bed he goes they put turkey
necks in my in my chest and I was like
what and then and he goes yeah I saw him
I saw the doctor take a bunch of turkey
necks and put them there put it all back
together I said no
no they're not he goes yes they did they
put he was convinced that the doctors
put turkey necks
in there and the reason why he thought
that is because about an hour before
about about an hour before he said that
the woman that brought him turkey next
came to visit him in the hospital
his neighbor so that kind of clicked he
remembered about the turkey necks and
got it conflated with his heart surgery
because he had what they call hospital
psychosis
where he lost his [__] mind in the
hospital it happens to the best of issue
yeah you know and uh
he thought all kinds of [__] he thought
that he had been abducted by a a cult of
people
and he was asking goober who was his
friend is his childhood friend he just
go down to my chest of course his name
is and of course name is goober yeah
well that's his nickname goober and he
goes good but go down he goes because
goo once you got to my truck and go get
go get my go get my gun
is it we'll look forward Tommy and he
goes we're going to shoot our way out of
here why every time I'm gonna shoot her
way out of here he goes I'm captured
because you've been captured I didn't
know nothing about that and he goes yeah
they're keeping me here oh because
you're gonna be all right you're gonna
be all right see talked him out of it
but he now later
I was there for all that I was like what
the [__] is he talking about you know
because they're gonna try to stop us
we're gonna shoot our way out of here
well we thought it was just we just
thought it was hyperbole you know he was
just [__] around no later on he
called me and he goes he was like this
is Weeks Later
he called me and goes man I thought I
had been abducted in Laurel you're like
yeah and I said you got you thought you
got abducted because yeah I thought they
had I thought I had been abducted by a
cult
and taken to uh and taken into that
hospital in Laurel and if they were
shipping me all around the place and
doing stuff to me and he and he goes I
thought it was a cult that was just
disguised
as the hospital I was like really
because yeah I really believed it
and I said you you told me that they put
turkey necks inside your heart and he
goes yeah they did and I said no they
didn't
because they didn't and I go no
why would they do that yeah and he goes
I saw that though and I said no
no now over time he was he would he
would start laughing about that [__]
like yeah I thought they put me back
together using parts of turkeys like
turkey necks and turkey stuff
turkey guts and [__] turkey necks if
they put my heart back together somebody
needs to write a graphic novel about
that turkey neck man like the latest
superhero made entirely of turkey necks
yeah no
you could be like some kind of
Thanksgiving superhero I don't know I
can see it I could see it
uh Mackie Mac VR chat says hi Tom and
Jenny glad to see you guys going strong
Pookie strong yeah she's actually where
is she she's around here somewhere she I
saw her like right before the show
started do we still buy CDs if so what
was the last CD you two bought I don't
actually remember I haven't bought any
CDs for a long time probably the last
one we bought was maybe one like at a
show like I feel like we've maybe bought
one at a show yeah like if we liked an
opening band or something we got those
for free
well no I know that but I'm just saying
like
didn't we buy a CD at that one show
where without where that opening band
was good and we bought their CD
oh that was and I got the shirt too did
I yeah what was the name of that what
was the name of that that's around here
somewhere yeah see that's what I'm
saying we never actually listened to the
CD yeah I mean like we have yeah like we
have a starry night CDs but like they
usually do used to give them Jasper yeah
Ben says I haven't bought a CD in
decades and it was mostly bands issuing
their own stuff as CD singles I mean I
still have a lot of CDs like I kept all
my CDs I threw it finally throughout all
my cassette tapes
like a couple years back but I still
have all my CDs but that's the thing
it's like I never listen to them because
I'm like hey if ever I'm in a mood for a
song you just [__] go and find it and
you can listen to it you know what I
mean it's like easier than [__]
digging out a CD isn't it
but I can understand why it's well it's
just like Onan because you like owning
movies yeah I like to have hard copies
of all that [__] I usually do what's the
product I did for a while but I kind of
feel like my thing though I like having
the hard copy of a book
do you know what I mean I like having
like a print book now for my book
reviews and stuff like that I've started
doing ebooks because I can't afford to
like buy a bunch of books all the time
but honestly I prefer having like a
print book I like reading print books
better than ebooks you know what I'm
saying uh and John Smith said not
getting into the vinyl Revival no I
never did I mean I don't have a record
player anymore I still have a bunch of
vinyl like from back in the old days but
and I know that there's
you know that a lot of uh bands are
issuing their stuff on vinyl now because
it's like a big thing but I just I don't
know I haven't got back into it for
whatever reason like I said I don't have
a record player and I don't have
anything to play them on and I have a
bunch of records that I can't play
hahaha
El paternity said last CD I bought was A
Tribe Called Quest love movement oh [__]
yeah that was a while back Ben said your
father learned the truth towards the end
yes he did that he was entirely full of
turkey necks and yeah
okay well that's just I don't know
that's just like really funny that's a
funny thing to like think yeah hey John
Smith
if you want to know more about the about
the uh the the war of Northern
aggression go on YouTube and go look at
a channel called rageaholic the real
funny guys heavy metal dude he's real
smart he calls himself razor Fist and
the name of the video is Abraham Lincoln
American dictator it's only from a
couple weeks ago
and he compiles all the real history
quotes
um recordings of what people said
because they lit a lot of people lived
into the early 1900s and actually
recorded a lot of their testimony and uh
now the the official narrative is not
really how it went down
but it's very interesting and what weird
is that it confirmed a lot of the [__]
my grandparents in the South said
and and their friends
yeah that's the way it really happened
and they kind of tried to erase that
part of History
um yeah he found out
it was because Clarice that that's the
the black woman that lives across the
street who looks looks after him
she came and visited him in the hospital
she's real nice lady uh big what you
would call Big fine she's probably like
close to six feet tall
uh maybe five eleven
um country uh girl and her husband also
real big and they had two or three kids
and my dad over the years kind of helped
raise the children he'd take them
fishing and hunting and stuff
um you know because
uh my dad has hunting rights on land
that's right in that area there's only
like 10 minute drive so he'd take he'd
take the kids out and they'd go fishing
and hunting and [__]
so he was kind of like the surrogate
Grandpa my dad
so he's kind of like a part of their
family in a weird way
and uh you know
there they saved the Clarice saved his
life she saw him out on the front porch
falling down the [__] stairs
and she ran out there and he was she
called she called 9-1-1 and got the
ambulance there and
you know had she not seen that
he'd have died
she got him out of there
and her her husband is like um
National Guard first sergeant
Army
and they're just I've talked to him
before but I haven't met him
uh but you know just real good people it
kind of like
regular country people from like a
Mayberry type setting you know out in
Heidelberg Mississippi population like
700.
it's a it used to be an old German town
but you know in um
uh Jones County Mississippi
well my dad's like the last white guy
all the other white people have died off
they just got old everybody else moved
away
yeah I mean it's a really small town
like I said little small town you can't
expect people to hang around to places
like that there's nowhere to work
there's nowhere to work there's nothing
really going on
if you're
some kind of a state or
state or government servant
like he is you know he's part of the
National Guard they're making money
um they tore down
the Mississippi tore down housing
projects and they went uh like section
eight where they said
they would Ascend those same people into
just lower Inc lower income country
housing which is a lot better for those
families
and uh they're re they're experiencing
there it's kind of like black Mayberry
okay that's kind of what it's like
their experience in the 1950s they had
parades with the cars some of that
shit's on YouTube you can go look at
Heidelberg Mississippi Heidelberg High
like a hundred percent black
but it's like a 1950s Style
High School
you know like something out of them
Greece that's what it's like
um
and you know people from there
the only way out if you're a young guy
is join the Army if you're a young woman
you got to get married
it's very traditional
you know so thanks well I mean I think
it's good I mean some people like that's
how that's how that's that that's the
that's the the that's the basic you know
what I'm talking about it's just basic
but you know a lot of good people come
from that that's where a lot of your
great movie directors and Spielberg and
all those guys came out of environments
that were like that well yeah they were
just a different color I know but it's
that's that's a good environment to come
out I'm just saying personally I'm not I
would not want to throw up somewhere
well you go back there it's like going
back in time
yeah but that may be a good thing
because they're real honest very
friendly people
okay
I don't know I kind of feel like
most people have dark sides and I kind
of feel like communities like that just
hide it a little bit better because
there's always all kind of shady [__]
going on behind the scenes always
I think it's looking at the wrong wrong
way they're just
most people aren't there for very long
okay the young kids
move away
okay but they'd come from a stable
environment so the area that they move
into they have morals to Anchor them to
help them survive
uh the the adults are tend to be kind of
like going into retirement that so
they're also stable it's very stable
it's boring
but it's but it it it's kind of a good
place to be from you know I'm talking
about it's not necessarily a good place
to live in especially when you're young
there's nothing really to do
well and like I said even from a
practical standpoint like you need a
career you need to make money to live
yeah you can't stay you can't stay you
can't stay no there's nothing you can't
stay if you stay you'll stagnate you but
it's a good place to be from like you
know what I mean it's like a it's like a
launch pad
yeah and like I said I'm not like
disparaging because like everybody's
experience is different I just said like
personally I'm not really into that kind
of you know just saying I'm just saying
uh chick Korea just died holy [__] he
was that he is still alive he's a jazz
musician yeah very famous
um
I didn't even realize he was still alive
was he a Scientologist he was a
Scientologist wouldn't he
I don't know am I totally wrong about
that I'm pretty sure chick Korea was a
Scientologist or he was like at some
point
John Smith said a better place to be
from than to have to go back to yeah
yeah it's that yeah every time you go
back you enjoy it you're I go back I'm
happy for a while and then then I then I
talk to some people and I'm there for a
few days and I realized why I left this
is mad at least had changed I kind of
feel everybody I know that came from a
town like that they say the exact same
thing yeah you love you love it to be
back in a few days later you're like oh
yeah yeah yeah I forgot this is why I
left this is why I don't live here
anymore
I mean like I said it's fine if you're
older like it's fine if you're like
retired or you know you're not you don't
have to work anymore you don't like want
to go out and do anything anymore or
anything like that like that's fine you
know but
I don't know I don't know I don't like
that kind of stuff but I know people do
and like I said
um oh it's been about a year okay check
her out of here oh okay I didn't like I
didn't realize I don't know who that is
well I'm talking to jazz music I didn't
know that well I wasn't either but I
still know who that is never heard
he's very famous sounds like a Japanese
Chef or something okay that's not
Tom does Tom doesn't know a lot of stuff
and he's like proud of not knowing it
Lance Bass is from Jones County really
yeah oh [__] right the free state of
Jones is he really it's a d what's Lance
Bass up to these days I feel like I
haven't seen him in a long time didn't
he like that was the one he was in that
boy band what the [__] was that boy band
which boy band was he in I don't
remember
so is Ray Walston from My Favorite
Martian holy [__]
I remember that guy that guy's not still
alive is he I feel like he was old back
then so was Parker Posey actress she was
in uh blade three and she was uh played
uh she was in uh what do you call it in
sync thank you yeah I couldn't remember
played uh Dr Smith and then the new
Netflix [__] lost in space I knew her
she was a friend of mine
yeah
she ended up moving to uh I was I knew
mostly her twin brother her twin brother
hung out with him a lot more than her
but Parker was [__] cute and Parker's
not her
real first name that's her middle name
Parker her first name is Missy
her name is Missy Parker Posey
she was cute as a bug back in the day
well last time I saw her she was still
pretty cute yeah yeah she looks she
looks kind of hard now you know what I
mean it looks like I don't know
looks real hard and tough well you know
people get old it happens to everything
yeah Ray Walston was also Mr Hand from
Fast Times at Ridgemont
that's right Jessica Lee
well that was Sean Penn yeah John yeah
don't miss your hand I got tools man I
can fix it I can fix it that's after
that car got [__] done I can fix it
we can fix yeah I can fix it my
[__] was crumpled up I don't
think we ever did we have a review Fast
Times at ridgeback I [__] love that
movie yeah you know what I should do we
should do a whole I feel like we should
do a whole 80s teen movie thing I've
been thinking about this for a while
because I've been wanting to do valley
girl for a really long time ever since I
saw that they added it I think HBO Max
maybe added it or something I was like
really excited because I haven't seen in
a long time and I love valley girl
valley girl that's Nicholas Cage when he
was really young and then you could do
all the like John Hughes movies you
could do pretty and pink and some kind
of wonderful and Weird Science you could
do all that kind of stuff
and then you could do Fast Times at
Ridgemont High because that's a [__]
great movie that's a great movie like a
[__] Sean Penn was it a Jason
Jennifer Jason Lee
you know
good [__] movie we should do that
you know we've done like all the 30s
monster movies yes we've done I feel
like that was one well if you want to do
a genre that we haven't yeah you gotta
do breakfast club we gotta do pretty
yeah Breakfast Club would be good too
pretty and pick now and then it starts
going into well we gotta do Weird
Science too
well to see there's nothing wrong with
that yeah okay we can do it how about a
nice greasy pork sandwich yeah served in
a dirty ass and what was the one
Relentless that was a that was that
other Judd Nelson flick where he played
a psycho in there Relentless wouldn't it
remember that one
it was like his last I kind of remember
what you were so yeah well see then we
might be getting into like when they
were a little bit older because then
it'd be like Saint Elmo's Fire yeah yeah
yeah I like St Elmo's Fire don't get me
wrong but that was kind of like college
graduates just going out and that wasn't
high school students anymore but I still
do like that movie but what's it yeah
Judd
um man what was that one
I know what you're talking about I don't
maybe that's what it's called I can't
remember
uh Tom Sykes said you already did Weird
Science didn't you I don't think I don't
think we did I don't remember doing
Weird Science yeah
grandfather says Graham still rubs one
out when Phoebe Cates gets out of the
pool
when I was in Korea when I was in the
Army in Korea the katusas
which are the Korean army augmentation
U.S Army in other words they were the
Koreans soldiers that served with us as
interpreters they spoke English and
Korean
they had this thing for Phoebe Cates man
they still had posters instead of Phoebe
Cates they were loving Phoebe Cates as
if that happened just yesterday and that
was already like I mean seven years
before and they're still when you're
young you're like dude man it was a long
time ago she's an old bat now yeah well
no she hadn't made anything in a long
time right she hadn't made anything in a
long time they were talking about Phoebe
Cates from Fast Times at Richmond High
and this is [__] 1991. well it made a
big impression it made a big impression
in Korea yeah for some reason because in
91 they were still talking about her
I kind of feel like people were still
talking about it in the early 90s here
yeah
because it made a big impression
Corporal song is like yeah I love Phoebe
Cates and I was like what
who Phoebe Cates baby kids come on
yeah yeah yeah yeah her her dad died in
the chimney on Christmas come on and
then the other Christmas
they were all in there and [__]
you're not funny yeah Phoebe Cates they
know about future well it's really they
had a he had a poster of Phoebe Cates in
his [__] in his uh what you call it
in his uh
dorm room like a Barracks room
that's so funny yeah I mean it's fine
like it's not funny because Phoebe Cates
is adorable but it's just like it's
funny how like because there's a million
like girls that are adorable and there's
a million like scenes like that so it's
just like funny how just one in
particular like really like strikes
at the time I remember looking at that
poster at the time and I was like she
looks a little bit Korean
so maybe that's why
she looks like she looked like the kind
of girls that Korean guys dream about
but that they're Korean girls she does
slightly look a little bit Asian a
little she looks a little bit Korean I
don't know if she is
I think she's Caucasian isn't she I have
no idea I I don't know I don't monitor
the racism celebrities it wouldn't
surprise me if she was Hapa maybe she
might have been half Korean I don't
[__] know
Zach says is Fast Times known for
anything besides the boob scene I mean I
kind of feel like that's the main thing
that it's known for
um but it's also known for the whole
exchange between Jeff Spicoli Sean Penn
very young and uh Mr Hand in the club
about the pizza and about this is our
time and that kind of stuff so that's
kind of like the other famous one but uh
just all around it's a good movie like
it's a good
High School Slice of Life kind of movie
and it um kind of I think the thing that
set it apart a little bit at least for
me like seeing it around the time I
don't know if I saw it at the time it
came out but maybe a year or two
afterward it actually it's funny but it
like took things like seriously like
abortion and stuff like that and it like
actually addressed that kind of stuff
like in a sort of matter-of-fact way
which a lot of the John hughese type of
movies didn't really do so I feel like
it was a little bit slightly edgier
maybe I don't know but that's just how I
perceived it at the time
that's how I perceived it at the time
but it's still like a good movie though
I really liked it
um I feel like it's kind of
I haven't seen it in a long time but I
kind of feel like it's sort of episodic
maybe but like I said it's kind of like
a slice of life
sort of movie which there was a lot of
those going around Louis says I think I
sent you guys Fast Times along with the
Breakfast Club about two years ago yeah
I think you might have I know you for
sure sent us Breakfast Club and I don't
and I really apologize because I don't
think we ever reviewed it
I don't know why we didn't because I
love that movie honestly I could
probably even review it without even
watching it again because I've seen it
so many times but I don't know I've kind
of been wanting to do
because we got back into Grace the other
day like we watched Greece and Greece
too and then like the other night I
think it was maybe last Friday night
after the Sidetrack show we actually
watched the live the live grease that
they did on Fox or whatever the [__] it
was
um we watched that again
and so I was kind of thinking man we
should do like some 80s teen movies like
I said we should do valley girl and we
should do some other stuff because we
did like night of the Comet which is
kind of like a horror movie but I liked
that movie well yeah I like that movie
it was a lot better than I thought it
was going to be yeah well like I said we
should definitely do valley girl because
I haven't seen that in a long time and I
really like that movie and like I said
that was like very young Nicholas Cage
and Louis said he sent us Breakfast Club
yeah and maybe Fast Times at Ridgemont
High as well I'm pretty sure I'm oh I'm
positive you sent us Breakfast Club I
don't know about five Times at Ridgemont
yeah we did yeah we didn't we didn't do
that one no we never did okay I gotta go
that's what I said I feel really bad
because it's like I remember he said
yeah and I was excited because I love it
if you sent any [__] we didn't do man
[__] remind me and I'll go in there
and get it because there were times
there were times where [__] like
seven videos would all show up at once
and we try I try to get them but then
some of them get pushed to the back
other stuff would happen I'll go back
and get them we're not real organized
not real organized sometimes yeah
it might that [__] might arrive on a day
where we were busy you know and then it
just got pushed to the back I've
forgotten about
El padrino said Hollywood Shuffle and
I'm Gonna Get You Sucka please review
these oh I will get you sucker oh I
really liked that movie I did too
[__] dude [__] pimp comes out of
prison with his [__]
fish tank [__] platform shoes that's
right I remember laughing at him and he
starts running yeah that was a [__]
great flick I remember that this [__]
was [__] funny I haven't seen that in
so long but yeah I remember really
liking that a lot oh my God I didn't
Phoebe Cates is married to Kevin Klein I
didn't know that how long have they been
married that's crazy
yeah Otto from Fish Called Wanda yeah
that's that's how I know Kevin Kline's
been in a million things but yeah that's
what I was remembering from too because
I love Fish Called Wanda that's one of
my favorite comedies actually and I
don't like a lot of comedies when you
were asking you if you're a pink lady
sure why not yeah evidently uh they're
having a whole series musical series on
Netflix called Pink Ladies
and it's the J it's the backstory to the
Pink Ladies
well no no no it wasn't Netflix
it's one of the other ones like [__]
peacock or something or everybody's got
their own Series yeah but like I said
that's kind of cool though I mean yeah
it's kind of a pain in the ass if like a
series you want to watch isn't on a one
that you have but I like that it's that
it looked good I saw the trailer that's
what I'm saying they look good after we
watched for some reason after we watched
Greece
somehow my Xbox knew about that and I
got the ad for that new
Greece series on YouTube
I need to have some [__] huh well I
don't know I think maybe they were just
sending that to everybody because that
kind of it was awful it's a big
coincidence
Zach says I always think of Kevin Klein
as the crazy dude Meryl Streep Banks and
Sophie's Choice oh yeah that too I don't
know why I just always think of him as
as Otto from Fish Called Wanda
Apes don't read philosophy oh Chris Rock
was in and I gonna get you sucker man I
gotta go see that again man I haven't
seen that in like I haven't seen it
since since it came out I saw it like
right after it came out on VHS [__] was
[__] hilarious John Smith said I
mainly associate the 80s with John
Hughes movies which looking back on it
they're kind of [__] up yeah some of
them aren't some of them are
um we didn't really think about it at
the time I guess like in the 80s but if
you watch them now there's some stuff in
there that's
a little bit I don't love uh the stuff
from was it Pretty in Pink or no it's
actually 16 Candles I don't love the
stuff with long dark Tong that's a
little bit racist a little bit who was
longed up dumb he was the he was their
exchange student
um he was staying with her family I
don't remember this oh my goodness and
uh your words is this no it's not a
series it's a movie it's 16 Candles oh
fake cheese guy yeah yeah yeah yeah
and you know what though that was just
the way it was remember remember Swan
from Mad TV
no I didn't watch Mad TV oh man you know
Mad TV had some had some good skits
swan
was it was it was a Caucasian commit
comedian chick she was kind of heavy set
she would dress up as a Korean woman
named Swan I mean I remember you showing
me that but I never I never watched that
funny and she could do the accent and
everything and she got robbed or
something she's talking to the police
and she's well can you give it a
description because she he was a man
but what do you look like look like a
man
well what kind of man he looked like
Like a Man look like a man
and she went on forever it looked like a
man you got it it was just a great skit
you know but uh that's just that's just
kind of what they used to do back then
you know you could dress up as any race
or ethnic group and [__] you know
impersonate him and do a comedy skit but
it was just supposed to be comedy but
the log duck dong character you're
talking about I remember that
it was just that it was cringy it was
very cringy it was just kind of cringy I
mean at least he got it he got a
girlfriend at the end yeah it just
wasn't there was a little bit of
transphobia in there too but like I said
that's to be expected because it was the
1980s they didn't really know any better
but the thing that bothered me the most
the the John Hughes movies didn't really
bother me the one thing that bothered me
even at the time was actually from
Revenge of the Nerds which I don't think
was John Hughes that was John Hughes was
it I don't know Revenge of the Nerds
there's that scene where the where the
nerd like dresses up in the costume of
The Jock boyfriend of one of the hot
sorority girls and has sex with her
under false pretenses because she thinks
it's the boyfriend yeah and then like
somehow she's like oh well he was good
so it was okay and I was just like
that's kind of not okay though I mean
nowadays like that's not that's not good
and like even at the time I was like
dude gross like what are you even doing
what was it again
you don't remember that scene like in
Revenge of the Nerds what
what was the scene
I just explained it I would kind of Zone
it out I guess I did I was still well
how about you listen to me instead of
like just asking me to repeat everything
don't worry about it then I don't
remember what you're talking about
trying to remember it it's a very famous
scene in Revenge of the Nerds yeah and
it's it's like now I have to repeat it
because you weren't listening yeah
you're not gonna listen you're not gonna
listen sometimes either okay so why
should I bother you're not gonna listen
this time either whatever
why I gotta repeat myself three times
okay
a very famous scene I don't know I don't
know which one is it which one
what what
scene I didn't even hit the goat
that's what I say every time he's being
like an old man because
back in okay this I'm gonna explain this
joke back in 1993
I went and saw the first Jurassic Park
in the movie theater with me and my
friend uh whose name was also Jen
so we went inside Jurassic Park and
sitting right behind us was this very
very elderly couple which I'm not
[__] it's like okay they have the
right to go to movies too
but they were like watching the movie
and they were like the guy was clearly
not really knowing what was going on in
the movie like ever I don't know if he
was deaf or couldn't really see all that
good or something so like his wife had
to keep like explaining like what was
happening in the movie because he was
like what's going on like he was always
like that and he I guess he couldn't
hear all that well because he was
talking like in a normal volume and he
was also helping everyone in the theater
by telling everybody what was happening
in the movie even though we could all
very clearly see what was happening in
the movie so the one part where the
dinosaur like where they put the goat
out like as the bait and like the
dinosaur eats the goat the old guy goes
it ain't the goat like really loud and
me and my friend just like [__]
cracked up so like every time like
Alzheimer's that's what I'm saying so
like every time like some
every time somebody like is watching a
movie and they're just like they don't
know what's going on or something like
that I always think it ain't the goat
because that guy is just like I'm just
like yes thank you sir thank you sir we
all saw that it ate the goat thank you
very much for pointing that out I was in
the movies one time with Jen and they
were people talking
oh my God people talking I remember when
Jim told me it was it was antlers
yeah Jen told him will you please stop
talking in the goddamn movie and that
[__] woman was so indignant you
stopped her from Talking they left
you're so entitled this and that and I'm
just don't [__] talk in a movie
theater watching your own [__] house
yeah you can do that now yeah
stream that [__] well see that's what I
mean it's just kind of like look if you
want to talk during the movie that's
your prerogative but do it your own
[__] house if you're out in public
around other people who actually paid to
watch the [__] movie then shut the
[__] up I don't understand why people
can't shut the [__] up for two [__]
hours what's so funny is that we had
that AMC uh
we had we had that AMC Stubs program
which you pay 20 bucks a month and you
get I think you got to see what was it
four movies a month or is it more or is
that it was three movies a week that's
right three movies it was a good deal
yeah we I would still have a lot of time
but if I what if I wasn't poor and two
if it wasn't so far yeah so [__] far
away because it's like it was a good
deal three movies a week that's like
that's yeah that's a [__] deal but
boy we started burning out on those
movies man I I [__] it's it was it's
almost too many movies if you ask me it
was fun for a while
um
but what's so weird about it is like how
dead the theater was most of the time if
it wasn't the weekends the [__] well
I mean we went in the middle of the week
usually well we went in the middle of
the week for that very reason because
there wouldn't even want a bunch of a
bunch of people because people are loud
and they won't shut the [__] up yeah
which is why I like to go see movies
when there's no [__] in there because
people can't keep their [__] mouth
shut the best experience really was the
Dolby Theater you selected on Dolby
Theater
uh kind of like on a slightly off night
and uh
man
we did that for a couple years didn't we
yeah
well yeah because we used to review them
right I gotta say most of those movies
are totally forgettable most of them are
yeah like some of them were good but you
didn't really like most of them didn't
stick with you no not really and the
ones that really didn't stick with me
this is going to piss some people off
the ones I would just instantly forget
was anything MCU
anything [__] Marvel Universe
I'd forget it almost instantly
they they just lack Soul they were
fun to watch in the way that it'd be
like fun to ride on a roller coaster or
something
but they they weren't you didn't learn
anything from them they weren't real
life changing in a certain way you know
I mean they weren't they didn't have any
kind of deeper meaning
and they were just it was just kind of
fluff
they made very little impression on me
some of the ones that made a good
impression on me were little two-bit
Independent films like the kid that got
that his parents made him to go to the
prey the Gateway [__] program yeah
that was [__] fun to watch that was
that I liked that movie yeah it made me
angry but I liked that movie yeah
because that was based on a true story
Dennis Quaid flick where the dude's
still living Intruder Intruder I still
liked it and that's like a [__]
that's like a [__] boy erased was the
one that you were talking about before
the boy erased boy raced yeah
um and then Intruder which was kind of
like a lifetime movie really like
something made for a lifetime but I
liked it I liked the fact that it leaned
into it knew what it was yeah it's like
we're just gonna be like a lifetime
movie but on the big screen yeah and
we're just gonna like be as ridiculous
as possible I'm like I respect that
choice I respect that choice
um another one another one that I liked
was the was that Keanu Reeves movie that
bobbed
the one about the clowns oh right I
liked it I kind of remember that one
yeah turn on his turn on his whole
family was clowns yeah yeah I kind of
remember that one yeah what the [__] was
the name of that I don't know but it was
like it had I feel like it had a one
name one word yeah but it was like it
was like the worst movie he ever made it
didn't make any money the boss it wasn't
that bad but no they they claimed it was
the worst one it didn't make any money
yeah but I liked the movie I thought it
was that right yeah it was I didn't love
it it was like an old 90s movie
yeah that's kind of what it reminded me
of yeah it reminded me of like a 90s
movie like hackers or something yeah
um
trying to think what else stood out
I liked a lot of the cartoons mid-summer
stood out well that's ariaster stuff
yeah uh fighting with my family stood
out
I still love that movie
um I really like fighting with my family
I like that too I thought that was great
I got that one on Blu-ray
um
just a lot of those movies didn't really
have character
nothing that would really
make it stick with you
a lot of the horror movies were kind of
generic even though they were enjoyable
at the time they just didn't really
well it kind of takes a lot and I love
horror movies I will watch them all day
long
you know if you paid me to do that I
totally would and I'd be totally happy
doing that but a lot of them I like but
they don't like make a huge impression
and the ones that make a huge impression
are kind of idiosyncratic like a lot of
times I can't really articulate like why
per one like particular one stuck with
me and other ones didn't like we were
talking on Wednesday I think some people
were talking about that movie sensor
because somebody recommended it and I
said that was absolutely one movie that
I watched and that really stuck with me
and but then somebody else said that
they thought it was terrible and I was
like well you know that's fine too but I
really really like that movie The Art of
self-defense made a huge impression on
me went right out and bought it Jenny
was amazed that I liked that flick
because I thought you would hate it she
thought I'd hit enough she said she
can't she can't predict what I'm alike
but no I thought it was hilarious but I
thought he would hate it I'm no good
writing and good storytelling when I see
it and that that was [__] awesome
excellent and that dude the dude the
dude that directed and wrote that [__]
from what my understanding based on what
people told me like he was like
diametrically opposite to the kind of
guy that I am but that doesn't mean I'm
not gonna like his [__] I know what he's
talking about yeah yeah but [__]
right that was a great movie
um great storytelling and Truth in it a
lot of Truth in it yeah
um he might have a slightly indifferent
interpretation of the truth because I
have a different interpreter I was in a
warrior a cult called the called the US
Army infantry and recompplitudes but
yeah that's kind of it that's what he's
talking about you know uh people he's
just seeing it from a slightly different
perspective but it is funny yeah it is
funny [__] it but here's the thing I
kind of feel like you don't necessarily
have to have experienced something to be
able to convey a truth about that
something yeah well it depends on the
person you know what I mean I did a
little bit of research and evidently he
said it
he was afraid of manly man stuff
it bothered him like going to the gym
and [__] like that
so that's really what the movie was
about
I kind of know what he's talking about
you kind of feel fear when you join an
army and you start going into this damn
machine that's about [__] getting you
killed I understand exactly what he's
talking about
and there isn't an amount of fakeness to
it
but not really
and what he's talking about is [__]
he's talking about the black dragon
Society they were like that too
and [__] oh what's his name uh
what was his name count Dante yeah Cal
Dante so he's got that mixed in there
you know uh so he did a little bit of
research
that there were guys like this
you know in Chicago in martial arts and
they killed people they did they made
bombs and [__] but they were dorks they
were [__] crazy too it's all part of
the so which like I said this is
somebody that's like a writer like me
yeah you see something like that and
they're like oh I could absolutely right
exactly exactly so yeah this is
something wild [__] [__] but this
that [__] like this happened in real
life and it should be discussed and you
should enjoy it well and what I was
going to say too was that creative
people people that write novels or
movies or whatever even if they haven't
necessarily experienced every single
thing that they're writing about that
doesn't mean that they can't understand
it and they and that doesn't mean that
they can't universalize that experience
because
you know um people's experiences are not
really as different as you think and
it's like even if you haven't done this
specific thing you might have done
something that was kind of comparable
and so you could kind of like read
yourself into that because you're like
well I did something kind of like that
well because like you were saying about
you know being like um you know feeling
like fake or being like afraid to do
this and that it's like everybody has
had that sensation yeah on some level
it's ever everybody has that kind of
like imposter syndrome kind of thing
it's like oh I'm not good enough to do
this or you know all these people here
are better than me or something like I
feel like 99.9 of humans can relate to
that on some level yeah so it's like you
don't have to have necessarily done that
particular thing to like relate to that
story and I feel like the best writers
are good at taking a very specific story
and like universalizing it so everybody
can relate to that scene yeah Graham
Grabbers
haven't been been a part of a [__]
police unit you would you would like art
of self-defense you'll know exactly what
they're talking about it's uh you that
movie will you'll understand it
and you'll you'll have a good takeaway
from it
um
and I thought it was from an odd odd
Source based on what I've heard about
the guy who wrote it and who directed it
you would he's like uh real [__] soy
you know is what you would call today
but no he got it right yeah I
yeah you got to give a man credit where
credit is due now he might have a little
bit different takeaway than I have but
everybody has a different perspective on
things but once you put your art out in
the world like people real good writing
real good right I mean like I said
people can kind of like tailor it to
their own experience and you can take
what you want from it that's kind of the
whole point of art I thought yeah some
people might say well hey man that's
that's like anti
karate or anti-martial Arts no really
the way it ends it's not though it came
back around and said and kind of Saved
karate and martial arts's
[__] it kind of saved its honor and
put a better person in charge
she was female
but so what she actually embodied what
the what martial arts was when the dude
that was just holding that particular
woman down and doing all this weird [__]
he didn't really about it
and then over there were several
generations of dudes that were faking
the [__] killing each other you know
um committing murder to get this Dojo to
be what it was which was kind of like a
violence porn cult where you go out and
commit crimes and [__] people up on
video to sell the videos he even had a
crematorium to [__] burn up the
bodies it was some [__] bizarre
that's not martial arts and they and
they killed the dogs and they killed the
dogs to replace it with tougher dogs and
I'm not a fan of that
they killed the dog
to toughen up toughen up old boy you
know and because his dog wasn't manly
his dog wasn't manly enough and then you
find out the dude that runs the dojo
picked the [__] because the the new
[__] [__] recruit because actually
the leader of the dojo was just like
that before he became who he was
so he was seeing himself in the new guy
um which it was seriously was toxic
masculinity Yeah well yeah that happens
yeah that happens all right it's a
monument to the fragile male ego that
whole [__] movie
and how it can go horribly awry I
wouldn't put it that way
that's what I took from it and that
should be just as bad what it was is
what you took from it was how
nerds okay
can't get involved in [__] like this and
slowly work themselves up into a frenzy
where they're not the good guys anymore
well yeah and we've seen that happen in
real life yeah that's what they're
talking about yeah nerds are not always
the good guys no right well it's working
themselves into a frenzy in a in a
warrior cult and they're now [__]
basically criminals but they are
criminals well the thing that it's kind
of showing is that it's not good going
from one extreme to another like if
you're just this kind of like oh you
don't even want anything to do with you
know this super masculine or whatever
you want to call it kind of [__] and
you're like no I'm just saying that
you're like afraid of that and then like
if it's like it's not any better to take
things to the total Other Extreme and
just like stir out and go and killing
people and just being an [__] for no
reason it was about nerds in a warrior
cult becoming criminals not for any kind
of goal directed violence
but to just make videos of it
so they could feel better about
themselves right you know if they
weren't trying to achieve any kind of
mission really you know uh I don't I
don't know it's fragile I don't think it
had anything to do with the ego I think
it had to do with [__] the desire
evil desires really
them trying to be stronger than they
were and their interpretation of what
strength was was to make money off of
making other people suffer
for no higher goal you know I mean so no
that's not what that is soldiers kill
people because they're ordered to to win
a war which supposedly is supposed to
achieve a higher goal which is to
protect your people
from evil
turns out most of the time that's not
actually what's going on okay including
Wars I was involved in they tell you one
thing but then it turns out no it's not
what it was it was about enriching
certain corporations inside the dam
military industrial complex now they
tell you what we're going to bring
democracy to these people no you're not
no you're not the Democracy will be they
don't want that that's going to be
rejected all right they want their
culture not yours all right this is so
where's the evil
or where is where's the fragile ego at
the bottom or at the top The Fragile
Eagle's at the top probably where you
have Elite people thinking that the
outside world wants the American way
they don't they want their own cultures
they don't want our culture they look at
our culture and think no that's bad we
don't want that
so you know
but
that's oh I'm gonna arrest you granther
says some 80s movies are a little cringy
now the Blue Lagoon oh yeah oh yeah man
I gotta see that one again horn on a
truck porn on a tropical island with
adolescent actors yes yes no I gotta see
I gotta see uh Blue Lagoon again I
haven't seen it since I was a kid that
was the movie we were watching before we
went to Mammoth Mountain
at Lois's house Louie says I remember
that [__] being cringy as [__] it was
cringy then
yeah I remember being pretty cringy uh
Louis said Jenny I can't remember if you
reviewed smile I haven't yet I did watch
I don't usually do this but I
accidentally
I had I think um who was it that it was
it was Brian Hollinger I can't remember
but somebody did a video about smile and
it was in my watch later and I just had
my little watch later playlist on while
I was doing something else and it played
so
I might have had the ending spoiled but
um on the plus side I don't really
remember like what happened at the end
not much but I'm I mean I'll still watch
it anyway
it does sound good but I haven't seen it
yet I haven't seen it yet
uh let's see just like any other demon
possession film I mean it reminded me
just from the way the person was
describing it like reminded me of
and I don't know I haven't seen it but
it sounded to me like somebody took like
the script of the babadook and like kind
of
copied and pasted but maybe I'm totally
off I'm totally off
Maybe
um yeah nerds I can't believe he doesn't
remember that [__] scene and [__]
Revenge of the Nerds like I said that
[__] weirded me out back in the time
maybe it did a weird dude's out I kind
of feel like maybe that's why
like Tom probably saw that back in the
80s and he's like yeah whatevs but it's
like I'm a girl so it's like I saw that
back in the 80s I'm like dude that's not
cool it's like I don't really like the
idea of like some Rando like dressing up
as my boyfriend and like having sex with
me and then being like Oh ta-da it's
somebody else I'm like yeah that's
that's not okay that's not okay but yeah
it's like in the movie like it was
totally okay and I was just like yeah I
don't like that like I don't like back
then I didn't like that
um John Smith said a good movie you
should go in absolutely blind soft and
quiet oh okay I'm gonna write that down
I'm gonna write that down you know that
one no but I'm just what is soft and
quiet what's that about it's a movie
but he said you should go in totally
blind I like to go into most movies
totally blind I mean I'll usually have
like a an impression like oh a lot of
people are talking about this movie or a
lot of people like this movie or
something like that but that's usually
as much as I like to go into it I used
to like watch stuff with my own kind of
thing now we're talking about since we
were talking about uh art of
self-defense and we were talking about
Jesse Eisenberg yeah uh once again we
should recommend vivarium oh yeah that
was another movie that made a big
impression on me made a big impression
and like I said maybe other people would
see it and they'd just be like meh
whatever but it's like for some reason
that just hit all my sweet spots I
really really liked that movie a lot
yeah it shows you some [__] on a bunch
of different levels it was very Twilight
Zone it was just very I just was really
into the whole vibe it was putting
across some people get abducted by a
[__]
trans-dimensional parasite slash kind of
like monster that makes you raise its
children
and you raise its children in an
accelerated fashion of the way humans
raise their children so it's almost kind
of like there's an analogy between
what's happening in this other dimension
and what happens to to you when you have
a family it's just that it's accelerated
a lot
it's a weird movie and I like too that
it also kind of explored yeah because it
was almost like an exaggerated version
of like what having a real human kid was
like where it's just kind of like you
have this kid and they're just like
screaming and needy and [__] like that
like all the time but it's like a
hundred times worse yeah it takes you
into another dimension it looks like
Suburbia and you gotta raise this child
it looks a human but it's not human I
just got into the whole look of that I
just got into the whole idea of that I'm
like this is I don't know if there was
something about that that really I loved
it I loved it it's an Irish movie yeah
it's the Irish director Irish knocked it
out of the [__] Park man it does a
great movie that was one that was
another one that affected me because I
learned from it see I gotta learn from
you you know what I'm talking about and
then I'll remember I'll retain it and
I'll want to watch it multiple times and
that one that one blew me away so other
people would see it and they go well you
got to look at it more deeply everybody
is different too so it's like I
understand that
you know movies that really resonate
with me particularly aren't necessarily
that's why I'm really hesitant like even
on my
on my own reviews like I'm always really
hesitant as hesitant to like recommend
movies to other people because i'm like
[__] I don't know you really so it's
like you might love this you might hate
it you might just be like man what the
[__] are you talking about and it's like
then you'll just be wondering what the
[__] I'm talking about like why I'm
recommending this and it's just kind of
like so I don't know it's just like hard
for me to do my Army bro chafino okay
from back in the day he saw it he was
like what the [__] was that what because
I that's what I'm saying I recommended
it and it's just he ran under he ran
underneath the curb you know it was Yeah
man they were another dimension he's
like man it's just dump
but he didn't really I don't think he
really got what was happening well some
people now look at it on the surface you
gotta [__] really think about what
the [__] is happening they're in another
they're in a false dimension forced to
re it's some people don't like movies
like that yeah it's it it's based on the
idea of a cuckoo you lay it you lay it
you make a nest and lay eggs in it
another bird comes and knocks some of
your eggs out and puts its eggs in there
and then you raise a [__] another
thing it's your kid but it's not well
that's what happens to these people but
it
The Nest is in another dimension it's a
it's an extra dimensional
alien of some some sort like a parasite
and it makes
parasites that look like humans it's a
[__] wild [__]
it's a wild concept I liked it
because I could almost and it's
something that evolved parallel to
humans on this planet a parasitical
life form
slightly outside this dimension
I liked that there was probably like a
whole back story that it didn't go into
like it just kind of like left it there
to your imagination like what would
happen if one day this happened to you
and there was nothing you could do about
it they were just normal people see I
like movies like that where it's just
regular people and they stumble across
this extraordinary situation and they
don't know any more than you and the
audience know so you so you as the
audience and the characters in the film
are figuring this [__] out and maybe
like the movie doesn't give you all the
answers but that's how it would be like
in real life if this was happening to
you I tend to like movies like that
because they don't over explain things
based on the back of those two movies I
became an Eisenberg fan he's got real
good tastes when it comes to what kind
of project to get involved in I know
he's been in some mainstream movies like
Zombieland there's some zombies I like
Zombieland yeah well we saw the sequel
in this yeah but the first one was good
I'm gonna go to the bathroom Okay
commercials we're gonna do the
commercials okay people I'm gonna talk
about a little bit but we gotta get
commercials in here at some times I
don't listen to her I don't listen to it
if I listen to her we wouldn't have any
commercials and
okay so let's play a little bit of
commercials I'm going to talk a little
bit
but uh no just on the back of those two
movies uh no Eisenberg [__] impressed
me like the guy's got really good taste
about what
um what kind of uh movies to be involved
with he he he's deep okay and if you
guys know any other good Eisenberg
movies I've only seen those two in the
zombie movies if you know of any other
ones these come out recently go ahead
drop in the comment section and I'll
watch those too because I'm a fan of the
guy now
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I'm back I'm not waiting for him to get
back from the bathroom uh all right L
Petrino said no one ever talks about
this one but I'll throw it out there
Ernest Goes to Camp do you know I don't
think I've ever seen a single Earnest
movie like I remember when that was a
thing I remember didn't he started he
started out as like a commercial pitch
man right I mean I remember the
commercials and stuff and then I
remember it kind of like segued into
movies but I don't think I ever watched
them like I said I'm a real weirdo like
when it comes to comedies I don't hate
comedies it's just not
my go-to genre and
a lot of comedies I just don't find
funny like but then like some comedies
I don't know it's it's really it like
again idiosyncratic like which ones I
find funny and which ones I don't
um
Zach says uh yeah Jesse I well I guess
he's talking about Jessica Eisenberg uh
so damn cute also tell him telling you
to watch The Social Network I've been
trying to get him to watch The Social
Network because it's really really good
I saw in the theater actually what is
that an Eisenberg foot yeah it's about
um Zuckerberg like the founder okay yeah
yeah people recommended that yeah yeah
it's good but while you were in the
restroom I was saying that uh if you had
any good
um uh Eisenberg movies to watch that put
drop in the comments section I'll watch
them he's got to have something that's
newer after vivarium and um yeah he's
been in some [__] but I can't think of
what it's hard for me to keep up you
know what I mean like I said I I really
tried hard to keep up with horror [__]
but even then it's just kind of like I
don't see everything right away I only
just watched [__] Barbarian like a
few months ago and that you know I still
haven't watched yeah uh you know I've
skin a meringue which I've been wanting
to watch because everybody's talking
about that one and it's just kind of
like I'm like way behind I only just now
watch the black phone that's how behind
I am
which I went the [__] did that come out
like last year yeah I only just now got
around to watching that pretty decent by
the way not great but decent that was
decent
do I think the Fletch films are funny I
remember them being funny I haven't seen
them in a long time so I don't really
know I'd have to watch them again I
don't remember I remember seeing them
back in the day and not thinking they
were particularly funny but like
thinking they were like oh like chuckle
worthy but not like hilarious El
padrillo asked me about Deer Hunter if I
liked it or not
I remembered liking it I like that movie
yeah I I haven't seen it in a long time
um but I gotta say when it comes to
Vietnam movies
the best one overall is going to be
Apocalypse Now especially the the
Extended Cut That nude Extended Cut
that's even better real good
even though it's not
historically accurate or anything it's
just a but sometimes
um going in a little bit of a more
fictional Direction gets closer to the
truth than something that's actually
more symbolically right spiritually
that's what I'm saying right
um which like I said which is why I
think like movies and novels and stuff
like that are important because
sometimes it can get closer to the truth
than actual truth does John millius
involved in that you know and he's my
favorite director actually he's Milius
um and he's into very nichean type
philosophies and
um
apocalypse now bro yeah that that's that
actually encompasses
America's War problem is that we don't
we never after World War II we never
really fought any real wars
they were more like police actions that
were half-assed and kind of doomed to
fail
the movie says basically symbolically
that real war is basically very
primitive and tribal
and you really own a win you really only
win Wars when you're at that level
and that's why the Taliban kicked our
ass out of Afghanistan corporations
soulless corporate armies like the US
Army can't win
against small tribal armies that really
believe in what they're doing
because we don't believe
if we believed we would just commit
genocide and Kill Them All
but that's not why we're there we're
there to make money that's what it
really is
so and that's what Apocalypse Now is
about
Colonel Kurtz was right
but it drove him crazy
but no he was right he became a
tribesman basically with a bunch of
mountain yards and stuff that's what war
really is it's not what these
what did they call them in the movie
groceries
corporate Grocers from the grocery store
you know uh it's not the messengers from
the [__] Grocers at the local store
to collect the build yeah that's all
that is anyway uh El padrenia said
please recommend new top horror movies I
need to see at least two tonight
um what ones are on the basket because
we don't know like I said I haven't seen
a lot of new ones either I think the
black phone is like the most recent one
that I've seen like I said I try to keep
up but there's just no way because
there's still like a lot of old [__]
that I want to watch or re-watch if you
you know if you're on the channel just a
couple of hours before we started this
live stream I put up a video review of
the first Coen Brothers movie Blood
Simple
um which I had been wanting to re-watch
for ages because I hadn't seen that [__]
since the 90s and it's just as good as I
remembered I don't know anything that's
uh nothing really stands out that's like
from now this year I haven't seen enough
of them in the past few years I would
recommend mid-summer if you haven't seen
that one if you haven't seen it see that
one I feel like most people have
probably seen that one we don't know I
mean well yeah I don't know but I just
feel like that's one that a lot of no
that's a rare movie I think the average
person hasn't seen that
I feel like a lot of people have seen
that I would see mid-summer
which is uh but again that's like you're
either gonna really really like it or
really really not like it it's folk
horror Germanic Norse folklore and I
love folk horror yeah if you like wicker
man you'd like mid-summer uh yeah it's
good that's from the scary white people
and they're ancient religions kind of
like the white version of [__] Aztec
temples and cutting people's hearts out
it's like that yeah you'd like it though
and
um you know I don't know I'm trying to
like think of some other stuff like I
said the black phone is okay but I kind
of feel like it was
I don't know I liked it more than I
thought I was going to it was different
than I thought it was going to be and it
was darker than I thought it was going
to be which I appreciated
um because I remember seeing the
trailers for it a lot and it was like a
Blum House movie and I thought it was
going to go one way and I'm just like oh
it's a little bit different than I
thought but
I don't know like like I said it's not
if you're talking about like Blum House
Ethan Hawke type of movies and even like
the same director and stuff I like
Sinister better
but black phone was still good
um but as I said if you're it went a lot
darker in terms of like showing
um child abuse than I thought yeah that
it was going to yeah see padrino had the
scene [__] that but he liked wicker
man he said it [__] him up okay then
if wicker man [__] up yeah if you
liked wicker man then you probably like
this because it's along the same lines
same concept but even better yeah and
honestly like I will if you have shutter
I don't know if it's still on there but
there is a fantastic three plus hour
documentary on there about folk horror
like the entire history of folk horror
movies and it's so so good I need to
like re-watch it this Summer's
mid-summer stars that little cutie from
uh fighting with my family what's RSP
yeah pew yeah she's cute as [__] in it
all right and uh
her and she was just in uh don't worry
darling I haven't seen it which again
I've been hearing mixed reviews about I
think it got some Oscar nods but her in
this movie her and some of her
classmates go to this
cult
kind of like this Norse Germanic cult
to see to to like study them for
anthropology basically
and one thing leads to another the cult
brings them in as guests and shows them
all their rituals and [__] goes [__]
sideways man that's a good [__] flick
weird [__] happens
in it
you'll see there's a lot like a lot like
wicker man I mean Ari Astor is the man
yeah I'm just saying
because yeah I told you like I love
Midsummer but hereditary is one of my
favorite horror movies ever you know
what I've seen it twice the first time I
didn't like it the second time I liked
it a little bit more it's kind of like
mid-summer also
the thing that I like about it Midsummer
has this too is that it really rewards
multiple watches because you can see how
much like meticulous
thought was put into every single I like
thing I liked it a lot better on viewing
too
there is so much [__] in that movie
that's weird it's like it's almost like
Kubrick level where it's just like all
the [__] that's going on in the
background that's like not mentioned and
it's just like all kind of [__] father
you know if you have if you haven't seen
that one see that one too what was it
called again hereditary hereditary yeah
see those two same and like I said
hereditary is kind of like it's one of
those movies that people either think
it's the best horror movie ever like
it's or it's one of the best horror
movies ever which I'm in that camp or
people like it wasn't scary blah blah
blah like so and that's fine like you
know people have their own opinions but
I hereditary we saw it in the theater
Tom didn't like it when we saw it in the
theater that movie stressed the [__] out
of me it gave me nightmares you're gonna
see both tonight and horror movies never
give me mid-summer spelled m-i-d-s-o-m
-e-r not with a U or ar it doesn't have
it he's got a spell with s-o-m-m-a-r
yeah
midsomar yeah and then hereditary I
would see Midsummer first
easier to understand hereditary is hard
to understand on first viewing it's
scary but you can't put it together it's
it took me a couple of times like she
said it's like a Kubrick move it's one
of those ones that you really have to
pay attention because there's a lot of
stuff that's unspoken there's a lot of
stuff that's going on like between the
lines of people's dialogue that's going
on in the background there's like all
kind of stuff that you really have to
you can't just like watch it in the
background and like not pay attention to
it you have to kind of see mid-summer
first because it's it's easier to watch
hereditary's more expert level it took
hereditary like I said and I and I love
horror movies and horror movies they
don't usually scare me that movie
[__] freaked me the [__] out it's
alien man it gave me it's weird it gave
me really bad dreams for a while it's
weird and that doesn't usually happen
and I know that doesn't happen to
everybody that was just me but yeah and
it's also folk horror but it's satanic
to be honest we saw in the theater and
it's like it stressed me out so like I
was happy because I was like oh my God
I'm so excited that I actually saw a
horror movie that actually like freaked
me out but then I was like I kind of
want to watch it again but I didn't want
to I didn't want to watch it again I did
eventually and it was like it took me a
long time to watch it again because I
was like man I don't wanna I don't want
to feel the way that movie made me feel
again but I did eventually
padrino has it he's gonna [__] I got
them both man I'm gonna see him tonight
yeah like I said just like just immerse
yourself yeah well and I would advise
that because I don't know I kind of feel
like there is your sort of and I'm like
I said I'm not [__] on it because
everybody has their own deal or whatever
but I kind of feel like
just people that are into casual horror
movies and it's just like they just want
to go see something like a James Wan
movie or something like that and it's
just like you know scary and fun and
like there's jump scares and [__] like
that and then you just go home and you
don't think about it anymore yeah which
those are fun yeah but it's like
honestly I was out of that one universe
that that had the damn
Mexican [__] ghost that scared the
[__] out of my your own yeah that was
from the conjuring conjuring Universe
yeah universities I think those are
overrated but I know a lot of people
like those I mean the first time story
was yes
it's good mainstream though yeah yeah
mainstream yeah they're good movies I'm
not saying that I'm just saying that
it's like those are the kind of movies
that all go and see that I'm like oh
that was fun I'll have some popcorn and
then I'll just go home and never think
about it again La Llorona got me
the imagery was good
I was I was I was riveted by it the
story didn't stick with me but some of
those some some of those scenes got me
the vision yeah I couldn't tell you what
happened yeah I couldn't tell you but
yeah like the visual visuals with
mid-summer and [__] hereditary it's
this it's the stories and the visuals
it's it's a lot better it's not his
mainstream you got to think about it
they're like yeah I like when there's
something more to chew on yeah when it's
like later on you're still thinking
about that [__] yeah you're like like
you can think about like the greater
implications of what happened in the
movie and it's like what about this and
what about like see I like that kind of
[__] yeah I like that kind of [__] I
like stuff that leaves an impression
and I don't have you know sometimes I
just want to watch something fun and
turn my brain off it's like hey let's
just watch a stupid slasher movie or
something like that that's fine I like
to do that too yeah but it's like my
favorite horror movies the ones that are
really going to leave a lasting
impression are ones that like that that
like leave me thinking about some [__]
yeah how long we've been doing the show
two hours and 20 minutes okay we're
getting towards the end we're gonna get
us something to eat what you want to eat
I don't know what do you got I got all
kinds of stuff I've got ham down there
on the bone still I can make any kind of
ham sandwich I can make [__] ham and
cheese omelette I could uh
I got the fresh biscuit
um biscuit batter
I can make a ham
and I could make a ham and egg sandwich
on biscuit I could do all kinds of [__]
um
I mean that sounds good yeah I got ramen
I think I think a Ramen I got ramen I
think ramen's always good
we ate salad already a salad a couple of
hours before I could come up with some
so is there any more questions people
Zach says I think hereditary is one of
the most emotional movies I've ever seen
it's weird that one makes weird yeah
it's like when I saw it I felt like
somebody kicked my ass like like
afterward and well and like I said I
think you didn't really
the thing about too complicated well the
thing about horror movies if you're
gonna like like I said I'm not gonna
[__] on people that just want to
casually watch horror movies and they
just want a good time and jump scares
and that's fine that's a whole other
thing but I'm like I want to get
immersed in the [__] yeah I want to get
I want you to pull me into this story
and freak me the [__] out like make me
believe this right and it's like so if
you're not gonna let yourself do that if
you're one of those [__] that's
all just like oh harm they never scare
me you know what I mean you're not
really letting yourself get involved in
the experience you know what I mean
you're just like pretending that you're
too cool for the [__] yeah I'm just kind
of like just let yourself get involved
in this [__] and you know the movie is
maybe not successful at doing that I'm
not saying that all movies are I'm just
saying that you have to open yourself up
to that experience and like let yourself
be traumatized by the [__] let yourself
empathize with the characters let
yourself really get into the story and
like believe that this [__] is real
otherwise the movie's not gonna affect
you and it's like why the [__] are you
even watching it my experience with it
being a basic [__] okay I'm just
gonna say I'm more basic when it comes
to movies even though I can appreciate
patient you know what I mean I know what
I'm seeing good [__]
between with that director and those two
movies I would recommend mid-summer
first because it's a lot easier to
follow it's a lot more direct hereditary
is kind of like
like you said it's kind of it's kind of
like a shining
it's it it shows you a bunch of [__]
doesn't explain anything you got to
really pay attention and figure it
figure it out and it takes a couple of
viewings it's a great movie
I didn't enjoy watching it the first
time I didn't get it well I didn't enjoy
it either but not for the same reason I
got it but I absolutely it made me feel
mid-summer I enjoyed I enjoyed it on
first viewing because I you know I
enjoyed it you know on first viewing
because it's it's it's a lot easier to
understand what's happened the second
one is a little bit more expert level
they're both great though they're both
great movies
it's just that that Midsummer oh excuse
me that hereditary is going to take a
couple viewings for you to actually
fully understand what it is that you
just saw
and it's more than what you just thought
it was
it seemed like a lot of random [__]
there's a lot there's a lot in there
it's not Spilled Out and some of the
[__] that they're showing you doesn't
make sense until later you gotta think
about it
yeah like I said you can't just like
watch it no and not think about it
things are happening and they're not
explaining it
so I'd recommend Midsummer first
yeah because that wins a lot more I mean
that has some weird [__] in it too yeah
it's weird but yeah but it's a lot more
like you said it's a lot more accessible
it's a lot more accessible yeah it's not
really trying it's not it's not a veiled
subject matter it's also you know it's
it's it's it's easy to understand what's
happening the other one is more like a
puzzle
I'm still honestly I'm still mad that
Tony Collett did not get an Oscar nom
for redditary is more like a puzzle
and you got to remember all those pieces
because later on they all come together
yeah you really got to pay attention
yeah but you know like like I said I
tend to like movies like that yeah I
know a lot of people don't and like I
said that's fine
um all right so we're gonna go get
something to eat I reckon yeah so we'll
probably be back on Sunday I'm not
really sure what movie we're gonna be
talking about I didn't check the votes
today there's a poll up so if you're a
patron you can go and vote for the
movies that we're gonna be talking about
on Sunday and Tuesday I don't even
remember what ones are in the poll at
the moment but we'll see
so we'll see which one we're talking
about on Sunday uh so yeah we're gonna
go get something to eat go watch some
more probably food to build America and
uh yeah thank you everybody for dropping
by thank you for super chats and we'll
see you guys again on Sunday evening
good night